le texte d'aujourd'hui il est fondé sur
des principes on a mis des principes en
avant issue de la campagne
présidentielle vous faire très attention
aux textes qui sans filtration arrive
d'une campagne présidentielle dans dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'en général ça
marche pas très bien et est en tout cas
ces principes sont à ce moment là très
très contestée et c'est évidemment pour
ça qu'il ya des débats très longs sur
l'ensemble de ces principes équité et
égalité universalité etc
c'est parce qu'ils sont au coeur de
votre texte et la vérité est que ces
principes ne sont pas au fond respectée
dans votre texte
et heureusement je reprends quelques
exemples sur l' euro cotisé qui donne
pas qui donne tous les droits
vous allez injecté beaucoup de points
comme il y avait des injections de
trimestre vous allez injecté beaucoup de
deux points tout au long du de ddd vie
de nos de nos concitoyens peut-être je
ne sais pas si vous avez fait le bilan
c'est peut-être 20 % des points qui sont
réinjectés puisqu'il ya une machine à
redistribuer qui fonctionne déjà
beaucoup et qui continuera à fonctionner
jeu sur le minimum garanti c'est
l'essentiel de la réduction des
inégalités au moment des retraites
lorsqu'on regarde vos différents
graphiques sur ce minimum garanti
ils expliquent beaucoup de cette de
cette redistribution c'est là aussi
évidemment une entorse souhaitable au
principe de l' euro cotisé
donc attention aux principes qui veulent
gouverner des textes merci chaque règle
48 n'est pas défendu le 446 non plus
monsieur bazin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la question
fondamentale en fait n'est pas dans les
paroles mais dans les actes de cette
réforme
vous reprenez dans la loi un slogan en
apparence clair et compréhensible
un euro cotisé ouvrira les mêmes droits
à la pension pour tous mais dans les
faits est-ce que cela va se vérifier
c'est la question légitime pour tous les
français pour chaque euro cotisé
auront-ils le même droit à pension pour
tous
la réponse est aussi clair et
compréhensible que le slogan c'est non
même le conseil d'état a reproché cet
abus de langage
d'où cet amendement qui vous propose une
réaction plus juste admettons que vous
recherchiez cet idéal relativiser donc
en fonction du réel à prendre en compte
alors il faudrait revoir un certain
nombre d'articles nombre d'articles
mettra ce premier article
il ya un tel écart entre eux le slogan
est l'effet que les français pourraient
se réveiller dans quelques années
complètement trompé par ce gouvernement
et sa majorité
la question de fond concerne le
rendement de leurs cotiser le rendement
sera-t-il le même pour tous cette
conversion de l'euro cotiser en pension
de retraite est tout sauf claire et
compréhensible
le taux de cotisation en fait pour
évoluer à la hausse le niveau de pension
réel pourrait évoluer à la baisse
l'inquiétude est légitime surtout pour
les générations nées entre 1975 et 2004
c'est important de le souligner et il
est important d'assurer la hausse des
pensions à l'avenir merci monsieur buzz
les moments suivant ne sont pas défendus
le 35 900 et pas défendu le 38 0 80 non
plus monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président ce jeu je
vais saluer notre collègue bazin qui
était un des commissaires les plus
attentifs les plus présents en
commission spéciale
la ford il ya eu d'autres y en ait
d'autres
mais monsieur bazin arrive aujourd'hui
la formulation retenue nous semble la
plus parlante pour illustrer
mais qu'est ce qu'ils vivent sur la
formation la formulation retenue nous
sommes la plus parlante pour illustrer
pour illustrer les principes retenus
alors j'entends j'entends que vous
trouvez qu'elle ne correspond pas à la
réalité du projet et on pourra y revenir
après mais il faut bien à des moments
donnés à voir des principes qui porte
une forme de deux philosophies de
l'ensemble du projet et pour faire écho
à des majorités précédentes je ne sais
pas si ça avait été traduit dans la loi
mais quand il y avait eu des slogans du
type travailler plus pour gagner plus je
ne suis pas sûr que tous les projets de
loi et se soit traduit absolument par ça
mais pour autant
c'était un principe fondateur de deux de
la majorité du mouvement et c'est dans
cet esprit là qu'on veut placer ce ce
projet concernant un euro pour tous un
euro cotisé ou les mêmes droits pour
tous des savoirs monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président à un mot à
la fois pour répondre au président à
lagorce et puis ça ça donnera un
éclairage aux députés les corbières qui
avec son collègue de la chaux
s'inquiétaient de ce que nous avions pu
prendre en compte dans les
recommandations du conseil d'état mais
je crois que c'était aussi une
préoccupation du député des rêves il en
fait c'est simple on a tous pris en
compte
on a gardé un point qui est une
affirmation de notre décision politique
c'est celle de m dans l'article j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir y arriver quand même
bientôt une disposition qui garantit aux
enseignants et aux enseignants
chercheurs à la fois leur niveau de
pension mais également le fait que nous
allons travailler avec eux à l'évolution
de leur carrière
voilà donc c'est simple nous avons
présenté le texte qui correspond aux
recommandations des conseils du conseil
d'état à l'exception d'une décision
politique que nous assumons complètement
qui est notre engagement
l'engagement du gouvernement vis-à-vis
des enseignants et
enseignants-chercheurs
c'est pas plus compliqué que cela pour m
eric woerth le président de la
commission des finances j'entends votre
remarque et je reçois votre retour sur
la gestion de la loi en 2010
mais enfin associé temps si on pouvait
aussi se dire que en tant que
parlementaire on peut aussi décider
comme ça sereinement que on n'est pas
obligé d'être un temps programmé et
qu'on peut quand même passé un peu moins
de 6 jours parce qu'on est raisonnable
qu'on a envie de produire la loi n'est
pas toujours obligé d'être contraints
pour faire les choses de façon
en tous les cas harmonieuse à moins à
mon île est un monsieur le président
vous savez le conseil d'état justement
sur cette disposition nous avait demandé
de préciser notre notre texte nous
l'avons fait et moi je crois que tout
cela s'applique dans des conditions
définies par la loi c'est un terme qui
est clair est d'ailleurs la loi ça tombe
bien c'est ici qu'elle se fait et c'est
ici qu'elle se débat avis défavorable
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
show oui pour un rappel au règlement en
vertu de l'article 6 alinéa 5 sur la
clarté des débats il a été dit que en
commission le président mélenchon avait
soutenu l'idée d'équité en contradiction
avec les la notion d'égalité et que nous
défendrons y ont donc des positions
contradictoires entre ce qui a été dit
en commission est ce que nous disons en
séance plénière je tiens donc à dire et
à citer précisément les propos du
président mélenchon mais exactement
toujours citer la source et ne pas
déformer les propos je cite
c'était de l'humour de ma part monsieur
le rapporteur je ne crois pas une seule
seconde que nous soyons tous d'accord
sur le fait que l'égalité est préférable
à l'équité la meilleure des preuves nous
l'avons eue pendant cette législature
lorsque le code du travail a été mis à
l'envers là c'est pareil il y aura une
retraite par génération les propos du
président mélenchon sont très claires
l'égalité l'emportent sur sur l'équité
et donc notre groupe et fidèle à ses
principes
oui à l'égalité non à l'équité et donc
pour la clarté des bas je pensais qu'il
était nécessaire que cela soit notée au
procès verbal
merci monsieur le show c'est toujours un
exercice complexe que de shit
les grands auteurs monsieur jumelles non
non oui sur l'amendement
monsieur jumelles je suis en pleine
forme c'est le président moi je trouve
que le ministre il un aplomb
extraordinaire parce qu'il nous raconte
tranquillou que le conseil d'état lui a
écrit qui lui a répondu comme s'il
s'agissait d'un échange eu de carte
postale que sur les enseignants tout se
déroule bien que tout était prévu qu'on
avait prévu l'air que l'application du
système de retraites allait plomber leur
pension et qu'ensuite on avait prévu que
le conseil d'état les nourrir toqués sur
notre volonté a tenté de rattraper le
préjudice sauf que monsieur le ministre
nous avons rencontré le secrétaire
général de la fsu il ya quelques jours
et que le dialogue engagé avec les
enseignants pour l'instant acte le fait
que vous soyez en situation de compenser
45 euros par mois pour les enseignants
sur les dix premières années
10 15 premières années de carrière
peut-être 20 on sait pas encore au bout
du compte on attendra que la loi soit
votée pour savoir quel endroit vous
mettez le curseur mais ce que nous
savons c'est que cette compensation est
bien loin de faire le lama il comme on
dit chez moi avec le poids du préjudice
que l'application de votre réforme 20
engagés notamment sur le fait que votre
décision inique de remettre en cause les
six dernières années dans le mode de
calcul des fonctionnaires est un
préjudice les six derniers mois dans le
oui pardonnez moi je suis un diesel je
prends un peu de temps le matin mois
avant de retrouver mes esprits mais au
bout du compte quand on se mobilise
plusieurs semaines il faut
laisser monsieur jumelles continuer non
mais en même temps lorsqu'on fait voeu
de silence et l'abstinence le risque de
se tromper est moins important que
lorsqu'on décide de tenir la tranchée
mais vous avez compris que les six mois
remis en cause dans le mode de calcul de
la retraite des fonctionnaires ne seront
évidemment pas compensée par votre
bricolage la boîte à outils improvisé
pour l'occasion en direction des
enseignants
je n'avais je n'aurais jamais pensé que
l'abstinence et le silence qui
caractérise les carmélites seraient des
traits comme on pourrait vous imputez
cher collègue monsieur monsieur daniels
ensuite oui merci monsieur le président
on parle on s'agite
les français nous regarde je ne prends
pas beaucoup la parole et j'ai donc pu
vous écouté avec attention et c'est aux
français que je veux m'adresser
car comme beaucoup d'entre nous je pense
à celles et à ceux qui souffrent des
injustices de notre système de retraite
actuel et qui attendent cette loi
je veux leur dire regardez nous écouter
nous tous attentivement et vous
comprendrez facilement que nous n'avons
pas la même vision de la société
certes c'est bien pour la démocratie ce
ne sont donc pas les députés qu'il faut
juger mais le projet de société proposé
par les uns et par les autres aux
français je veux toujours dire aux
français nous devons et prendrons nos
responsabilités parce que vous nous avez
élu pour vous représenter
et donc pour construire un système de
retraites plus juste plus solidaire et
plus humain un système économiquement
viable socialement équitable et
sociétalement humaniste c'est cela notre
projet mes chers collègues il est clair
bien sûr il doit être amendé sur le fond
et je souhaite que nous puissions
réussir s'il vous plaît chers collègues
de l'opposition
aidez nous à comprendre le vôtre celui
que vous voulez pour les français par un
débat à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités d'élu député élu
démocratiquement par les français merci
merci monsieur bazin merci monsieur le
président voilà je sais pas si ça avait
un lien avec le l'amendement en question
mais comme j'ai compris qu'il y avait un
jeu entre certaines oppositions et la
majorité pour arriver au 49 3 ne nous le
souhaitons pas du tout et on souhaite
revenir sur le débat de fond on a
proposé un amendement
on a proposé un amendement qui reprend
une formulation sur laquelle moi
j'aimerais qu'on puisse débattre les
mêmes doigts selon leurs cotisations et
moi je vous pose une question
fondamentale
monsieur le ministre monsieur rapporteur
sur ce taux de rendement est ce qu'une
personne née en 1974 aura la même
retraite qu'une personne née en 1976 en
ayant cotisé autant d'euros est ce que
vous êtes capable de le garantir et de
répandre devant tout le monde parce que
vous avez un slogan est ce que dans les
faits ils se vérifiera répondez à cette
question ça nous permettra de nous
rassurer
alors mon âme rabbo effectivement la
question de notre collègue est
extrêmement pertinente je vais reposer
je sais que au fini par se répéter mais
l'art de la répétition peut parfois être
utile monsieur le ministre prenons le
cas de deux jumelles
mais j'ai reçues il aimerait jumelles au
féminin bon chien une une qui né le 31
décembre 1974 à 23h50 et l'autre qui né
le 1er janvier 1975 à 00h10 fin à une
heure enfin 00h10 mans non mais monsieur
le ministre pouvez vous nous dire si ses
deux jumelles commence à travailler
le même jour ont la même durée de
cotisation exercent le même métier ont
le même salaire tout au long de ma
carrière
pouvez vous nous dire oui ou non que ses
deux jumelles ne rompt pas la même
retraite avec la réforme que vous
engager je vous remercie merci nous
allons donc passer au vote de
l'amendement présenté par monsieur s'il
vous plaît monsieur assure ce avant - ah
bon madame o talès il
oui j'avais précisément demandé la
parole chez d'un moment parce que à ma
connaissance ceci j'ai eu un moment
d'absence ce matin ni le rapporteur ni
le ministre n'ont répondu aux contenus
de l'amendement de l'opposition d'en
face à droite
or il est écrit dans ces amendements
qu'il s'agit de garantir les mêmes
droits pour tous selon leurs cotisations
or c'est précisément ce qui est dans
cette loi puisque parce qu'il y a une
notion d'équité et un régime à points et
c'est en réalité ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'on va toucher au plus près de
ce que l'on aura cotisé c'est bien
pourquoi
le but affiché mais la réalité aussi de
ce qu'il ya dans la loi va se
transformer va se transformer par une
mise à sac de tous les mécanismes de
solidarité et qu'on est bien dans une
logique méritocratique qui ne permet pas
d'aboutir véritablement à l'égalité je
vais prendre un exemple sur la fonction
publique
la fonction publique il y à la sécurité
de l'emploi mais il ya également des
salaires qui sont plus bas que dans le
privé
et quand la règle de calcul s'est fixé
sur les 6 derniers mois et non sur
l'ensemble de la carrière ou non sur les
10 meilleures années où les 25
meilleures années dans le privé c'était
pour une raison simple c'était pour
arriver à des pensions à égalité à
égalité en termes de taux de
remplacement par rapport au privé
c'était justement pour que au moment de
la retraite
on n'est pas des retraités de la
fonction publique beaucoup plus
défavorisés que dans le privé c'est ça
donc l'égalité c'est bien l'objectif
tedder d'arriver à une réalité d'égalité
alors que l'équité c'est le principe de
départ méric autocratique on va
rapprocher par rapport à ce qu'on cotise
ce que l'on va ensuite touché donc je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous refusez
l'amendement de la droite ou en tout cas
pourquoi vous ne vous exprimer même pas
dessus et surtout je pense qu'en réalité
c'est bien l'équité que vous recherchez
et qui arrive demain et qui n'a rien à
voir avec l'égalité véritable mur sud
monsieur petit merci monsieur le
président très rapidement d'abord nous
ne votons pas cet amendement enfin moi
je ne le ferai pas parce que c'est un
amendement d'affichage et que j'aimerais
qu'on arrive sur le fond et deuxièmement
si je comprends bien je vais relire le
projet de la france est soumise par ce
que je comprends bien qu'on aura tous la
même retraite alors c'est ça que vous
proposez dire qu'il faut qu'on ait tous
la même retraite je vous rappelle que
dans notre projet ce qui aujourd'hui
cotisent pour avoir des retraites énorme
ne leur ont plu donc nous nous avons
déjà commencé à raboter et je comprends
que je vais trouver dans votre projet
que quand on part à la retraite à 60 ans
on a tous par exemple temps d'euros et
que ce sera sa légalité
quel que soit son et cotisé etc il
faudra que vous mettez d'accord avec vos
collègues du groupe gdr qui ont dit hier
que eux ça leur paraissait injuste que
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais travaillé et la
même retraite que quelqu'un qui a
travaillé
merci merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 24,615 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur et du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin public
des amendements identiques 7 et suivants
tout le monde a regagné sa place le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos votants 91 exprimé
88 majorité 45 pour 17 contre 71
amendements ne sont pas adoptées
monsieur jumelles pour le 25000 618
amendements et suivant pour lesquelles
je suis saisi par le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine d'une demande
d'un scrutin public de scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale merci monsieur le président
l'instauration de l'âge des clips ray de
fortes inégalités de forte injustice
entre les salariés d'une même génération
il permet d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a
été inventé pour cela de raboter les
bastions les pensions de ceux qui
souhaitent partir à 62 ans à l'âge
déquilibre je prends deux exemples là je
vais vous épargner d'avoir deux jumelles
dans cet hémicycle
je vais donc prendre une employée et non
75 qui commence à travailler à 20 ans
dans le système actuel ne cotisera 43
ans 20 ans elle partira à 60 3 ans à
taux plein c'est désormais la durée
exigée depuis la réforme touraine dans
le système projetez vous les savez pour
partir sans décote
elle partira à 65 ans ayant l'obligation
de travailler 45 ans al'inverse le cadre
n'est en 75 qui lui commence à
travailler à 60
à 23 ans pardon dans le système actuel
il part à 66 ans à taux plein 23 + 43
depuis la loi touraine 63 ans et dans le
système crocheter elle pourra partir à
65 ans pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein et donc avoir travaillé simplement
42 ans voilà l'une des illustrations de
votre conception de l'équité et de
l'égalité vous l'appelez comme vous
voulez au bout du compte de la
discrimination qui vise à pénaliser ceux
qui ont moins
c'est d'une certaine manière la
solidarité à l'envers votre histoire
merci monsieur la chaumusse corbières
pour un sous-amendement oui disent merci
président monde la discussion est
franchement très intéressante et je
remercie le ministre tout à l'heure
d'avoir fait payer très cher guide
d'avoir répondu effectivement aux
questions que nous vous posions sauf que
je dois vous dire avec beaucoup de
respect la réponse que vous nous avez
fait nous placent encore plus dans une
forme de confusion vous a dit nous avons
tenu compte du conseil d'état je vous
cite vous corrigerez si je déforme vos
propos notamment concernant les
enseignants et les chercheurs et vous
avez évoqué la revalorisation que vous
prévoyez sauf que précisément le conseil
d'état qui insiste ex né le 24 janvier
vous met en cause sur cette affaire-là
et considère qu'il est précision
anticonstitutionnel de mettre en place
une loi qui fait une injonction de faire
une autre loi qui valorisera notamment
les enseignants on est là face justement
à une difficulté majeure qui montre que
la méthode que vous avez choisi est
assez est assez chaotique créer des
possibilités de rendre nos travaux
anticonstitutionnel il y aurait mieux
valu d'ailleurs engagé la revalorisation
des enseignants la même façon d'ailleurs
sur la conférence de financement faire
tout ce travail et une fois que les
enseignants seront valorisés et
peut-être engager votre réforme des
retraites vous avez fait l' inverse
mais c'est assez piquant mais vous allez
peut-être me répondre pour préciser des
choses que vous évoquez la prise en
compte nous de la revalorisation des
enseignants qui est spécialement points
de fragilité que le conseil est à vous
avez remarqué
donc finalement votre réponse qui me
voulait éclairer les choses a participé
à la confusion j'espère monsieur le
ministre que vous aurez à coeur de
préciser les choses
merci sur cet amendement qui vient
d'être exposé je suis saisi par le
groupe la france insoumise d'une demande
de scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale sur l'ensemble monsieur le
rapporteur amendements et sous
amendement merci monsieur le président
je trouve surprenant que les
argumentations n'ont rien à voir avec le
contenu même de l'amendement me
j'entends votre propos monsieur jumelles
mais là votre votre amendement c'était
remplacer les euros cotisés ouvre les
mêmes droits par les heures travaillées
ouvre des droits
donc les heures travaillées ont de fait
puisqu'il ya un salaire ouvrir des
droits mais la notion d'euros nous
sommes le plus équitable parce que les
heures ne donne pas lieu forcément même
salaire mais c'était pas votre
argumentation et et monsieur et monsieur
corbières lui c'était pas les heures
mais c'étaient les périodes donc
examinons le font parce que j'ai peur
que vous souhaitiez faire des
amendements pour qu'on discute de la
philosophie du texte
nous ce que nous voulons c'est rentrer
dans le détail du projet et que sur des
éléments de détail précis technique vous
nous portez vos arguments que nous
essayons d'y répondre mais là nous
restons dans la philosophie et donc
défavorable dit monsieur le ministre
allez merci monsieur le président
défavorable un mot pour mais je suis
d'accord bien j'ai dit à l'exception de
à l'exception d'un parce que nous avons
souhaité porter un message politique
clair qui est notre engagement vis-à-vis
des enseignants et des chercheurs
monsieur monsieur bazin la question de
l'âge de l'année de naissance
sur le fond elle n'a d'intérêt que très
peu au regard du fait qu on ait ou pas
dans le système universel de retraite
quelle que soit notre à des naissances
si on est concerné par le système
universel de retraite c'est à dire si on
est à plus de 17 ans de la retraite
quel que soit notre âge de naissance et
bien tout ce qu'on aura cotisé dans le
système universel de retraite nous
donnera les mêmes droits pour la part
contributive
après il ya une chose que ni vous ni moi
ne pouvons savoir sait quel sera le
parcours de vie de ce que vous voulez
imaginez avec nous ce matin
quelles que soient leurs oeuvres ou leur
année de naissance est-ce que idw elles
auront des enfants haut komo frontil en
matière de choix de répartition pour la
part de majoration de la pension qui
sera affecté aux
quand même si vous avez souligné 3 mais
bon voilà je dirais donc évident oui je
veux je comprends la fois votre question
je veux vous rassurer sur le fait que
quand on sera dans le système universel
de retraite dès qu'on est à plus de 17
ans de la retraite on a une part de
toute façon qui sera au titre de ce
système universal la partie contributive
donnera les mêmes droits la question
aussi on n'a pas évoqué mais la
pénibilité moi si j'ai un métier qu'il
ya de la pénibilité
j'aurais peut-être aussi un départ qui
sera pas en même temps que celui ou
celle qui n'a pas de pénibilité même si
elle est née six heures ou six mail ou
six minutes avant après qu'on soit
jumeaux jumelles voilà c'est la limite
de ces de ces cas particuliers sur
lequel je madame la présidente rabot
vous vous aimez cette situation vous
l'avais proposé voilà à plusieurs
reprises ces on a je crois que c'était
un peu l'idée aussi en miroir de la
question du député bazin qui était de
nous dire sur le fond vous avez choisi
de faire des transitions longue donc
effectivement quand on est à moins de 17
ans de la retraite on n'est pas concerné
donc le débat d'abord idée simple quand
on est à moins 10 stands après tout on
n'est pas concerné qu'on tournait à plus
de 17 ans on aura une part de sa
retraite qui sera liquidée dans le cadre
du système universel de retraite
et puis une part de sa retraite qui sera
a dit quitter dans le système pour
lequel on a ou les systèmes souvent cédé
1 plus de 3 en moyenne pour les français
pour les systèmes où on a cotisé
alors vous me posez la question d'une
date butoir pointant effectivement la
question de l'effet de seuil
on pourrais je le fais vraiment avec
bienveillance qu'on pourrait se poser la
même question pour les générations par
exemple 72 et 73 avec la durée
d'activité de la loi touraine voyez on
pourrait se poser la même question des
deux jumelles
donc en fait ce sujet là ce sujet dax
logique vous pointez c'est que lorsqu'il
ya une évolution des règles qu'on prenne
comme référence collective la durée
d'activité où l'âge déquilibre les
questions se posent elles sont valables
pour nous tous donc c'est pour ça que
nous avons choisi de faire des
transitions longue avis défavorable
monsieur le président qui est beau
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais juste hâte à venir pour
apporter quelques précisions
et pour réinstaurer un peu une vérité on
parle aujourd'hui d'un système à 43 ans
c'est faux c'est faux parce
qu'aujourd'hui le système l'âge de
départ de retraite au taux plein est
calculé en fonction des trimestres or on
peut avoir travaillé plus de 43 ans sans
avoir cumulé l'ensemble des trimestre
c'est-à-dire soit 171 soit 175
je prends l'exemple aujourd'hui je fais
partie à mon cas je suis élu que depuis
deux ans j'étais avant dans un système
qui est le système qui est concerne 65 %
des français qui est de régimes de base
plus la complémentaire agirc arrco
qu'est ce qui se passe actuellement mon
âge à taux plein de la retraite l'état
66 ans et demi pourquoi passer si je
pars donc j'ai commencé à travailler en
cdi à 42 ans parce que mes boulots que
j'ai fait que j'ai fait avant seront
essentiellement les petits contrats ne
sont pas comptabilisés il ne permet pas
de valider des des mois comme on veut le
faire ni des trimestre donc du coup
j'arrive à un taux plein normalement de
65 ans or j'ai une carrière hachée j'ai
eu trois périodes de chômage qui me
repousse encore mon taux plein à 2 à
partir de là linge écart qu a pris la
décision sans avoir averti qui que ce
soit d'ailleurs que si on part à taux
plein la première année nous avons
automatiquement minoration de 10% d'iran
dit durant pendant trois ans pour ne pas
avoir cette minoration faudrait que je
travaille encore une année
supplémentaire
donc non pas à 43 mais 44 ans ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui j'arrive à 66 ans et demi
avec ce nouveau système que nous voulons
mettre en place
moi pour ma part je rentrerai pas dans
parce que chinois 72 j'aurais pu partir
à taux plein effectivement avec un hdd
code qui n'ont plus d'animations la
décote non plus à 67 mais à 64 j'aurais
pu partir à taux plein à 64 65 ans voilà
donc j'aurais gagné à peu près qu'on
peut plus de deux ans merci merci
monsieur woerth
si monsieur merci monsieur le président
on n'a pas le temps de débattre mais non
c'est pas le cas ce serait pas que ces
périodes de chômage sont comptabilisés
en trimestre et s'est donc mais c'est
pas le cas ça à ce que ce que vous dites
est faux vous projeter dans un système
qui n'existe pas donc garder en tête que
je veux juste reprendre l'exemple de
madame ragot moi jouer un employé des
jumeaux et pas des jumelles parce que je
des deux jumelles ça fait beaucoup pour
l'assemblée mais sur les jumeaux de
conducteurs de tram conducteurs de train
ils sont deux ils là est né le 31
décembre 84 à 23h59 il part à 50 2 ans
et l'autre est né le 1er janvier 0,1 g à
00h01
il part à 62 ans est ce que c'est le cas
quelle est la phase de transition
comment vous allez augmenter les halles
toutes ces questions là se pose
évidemment elles ont été posées prendre
chaque fois qu'on avance on pose de
nouvelles questions où on réédite
d'anciennes question on voit bien que ça
pose beaucoup de problèmes parce que les
phases de transition sont d'une langueur
extrêmes et les phases de transition qui
sont d'une longueur extrême elle
complique énormément la lecture du sujet
et il ya des transitions qui sont
extrêmement choquantes notamment celles
que par exemple vous allez augmenter les
fonctionnaires pour que juste ça puisse
garantir leur niveau de pension et vous
allez prendre en compte l'état va
prendre en compte les cotisations
l'augmentation des cotisations des
fonctionnaires notamment par exemple sur
l'assiette sur l'augmentation de
l'assiette et tout particulièrement sur
les primes donc il n'y a aucune équité
là dedans si juste la volonté d'avoir un
peu de paix sociale n'y a pas d'équité
vous prenez 20 ans pour le faire ou 19
ans pour le faire donc ça veut dire que
c'est quasiment une génération
donc c'est très critiquable et ça va à
linverse de l'ensemble des principes que
vous mettez en que vous voulez mettre en
oeuvre sur cette chose cette réforme
je pense qu'il faut que vous la hune
métier ou que vous changiez monsieur à
rêver
oui merci merci monsieur le président
effectivement la question qui a été
posée à la fois par un parti beauvoisin
par valérie rabault sur la différence de
traitement à quelques jours d'écart à
quelques semaines d'écart entre ceux qui
sont nés en fait avant le 1er janvier 75
et ceux qui sont nés après n'a pas
trouvé de réponse pour l'instant dans la
discussion que nous avons et j'ai trouvé
que monsieur bazin avait posé la
question de manière fort éloquente
savoir si voilà qu'est ce qu'ils auront
droit à la même retraite
quelle sera la différence de traitement
entre les deux et entre les deux
systèmes
voilà donc jeu mais si ça existe bien
sûr que ça n'existe pas le problème
qu'ils soient fraîcheur des personnes
qui vont voir partir qui sont mis avant
le 1er janvier 75 et d'autres après
voilà quel sera l'écart entre les
retraites
voilà quel sera l'écart entre leur
retraite la deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que nous pour ce qui
nous concerne nous sommes opposés à la
monétisation que vous êtes en train de
mettre en oeuvre des heures de travail
c'est ça le finalement le calcul par
point tel que vous l'imaginez est donc
cette monétisation pour nous elle
conduit à toutes les dérives que j'ai
expliquées dans la conception du droit à
la retraite mais aussi dans la
conception du travail lui-même où on est
toujours là dans le travailler plus pour
gagner plus pendant son travail pendant
sa retraite pour garantir sa retraite on
sait qu'il va falloir acquérir un
certain nombre de points etc
c'est une rupture par rapport aux
systèmes précédents et donc nous savons
par ailleurs que 1 euro cotisé
aujourd'hui dans le système actuel donne
plus de droits pour les bas salaires que
pour les hauts salaires ça c'est une
vérité que vous êtes en train de
remettre en cause avec le principe que
vous mettez sur la table aujourd'hui un
euro cotisé donnant plus de droits pour
les bas salaires que pour que pour les
hauts revenus
donc je sais pas comment vous répondez à
7 à cette question là mais ça me semble
être une question mr
donc ça montre monsieur le président
qu'en réalité vous êtes en train de
créer un sac de noeuds et je crois que
ce n'est pas sérieux
merci veut donc procédé aux différents
scrutins
nous commençons par le sous-amendement
40 271 qui a reçu un avis défavorable du
rapporteur et du gouvernement
tout le monde a regagné sa place le
scrutin est ouvert ce que tu es un clown
ça marche pas votants 88 exprimé 79
majorité 40 pour 8 contre 71
nous allons maintenant passer au vote
d'un amendement 25 1618 et identiques
qui reçu un avis défavorable du
rapporteur et du gouvernement
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos votants 88 exprimé 79 majorité 40
pour 10 contre 69
ces amendements ne sont pas adoptés
alors un amendement 25 1340 il n'est pas
défendu donc elle
en banlieue de stockholm cette vieille
dame aime passer du temps dans cette
petite parcelle en plein hiver pour
cette retraitée jardiner n'est pas
seulement un hobby à cultive parce que
c'est une activité qu'elle aime bien
mais elle cultive surtout parce que ça
la perte ça lui permet de faire des
économies de survivre je fais pousser
des poivrons des tomates dans ma serre
mais aussi des pommes de terre des
carottes des betteraves pour survivre
nous dit elle
parce que figurez vous que nos
inquiétudes nous critiquent une certaine
manière nos certitudes sur votre mauvais
projet réside dans le fait que les
retraites par points y compris déguisée
de mots volent et d'universalité
d'équité de redistribution ont été mises
en oeuvre dans d'autres pays d'europe
la suède en est l'illustration
l'allemagne en est un autre je disais
hier qu en allemagne
l'ensemble des forces politiques ont été
obligés de se réunir dans l'urgence pour
mesurer à quel point cette retraite par
points avaient aggravé la pauvreté des
personnes âgées dans ces pays respectifs
monsieur le ministre
est-ce qu'à l'échelle européenne vous
avez échangé avec vos homologues pour
voir à quel point cette retraite par
points nous n'en voulons pas redondant
ce n'est pas autorisé
continuez monsieur je me suis pas
compris ce qui se passait un film en
courtes âtre très bien mais enfin vous
avez compris le sens de ma question est
ce que vous échangez à l'échelle
européenne
ou est-ce que c'est l'échelle européenne
et la réflexion libéral qui vous guide à
imposer ça chez nous enfin nous les
jardins à l'allemande les jardins
al anglaise les jardins qui vise à
démanteler notre modèle de protection
sociale à la française on n'en veut pas
parce qu'on sait ce que ça donne dans
les pays où saïd est mis en oeuvre
merci il ya un sous-amendement monsieur
bazin pardon monsieur signe merci oui
c'est un pan de notre collègue marc le
fur l'amendement numéro 25 617 vise à
rappeler que chaque heure travaillée
doit ouvrir des droites dans compte des
spécificités de chaque métier notamment
pour les métiers liés aux suggestions de
série public le présent sous amendement
vise à préciser que doivent être prises
en compte les spécificités de fonctions
exercées par les fonctionnaires régalien
notamment les militaires policiers
gendarmes et pompiers qui assurent la
sécurité des français pas porter sur
l'ensemble
merci monsieur le président sur
l'amendement lui-même je vais redire
s'était dit à plusieurs reprises mais je
vais le résumé dernière fois sur le
système par points le système par points
et traite et est une unité
d'enregistrement des droits ça c'est une
certitude mais du système par points il
y en a deux de diverses teneur et le
système suédois et le système allemand
ne sont pas celui que nous voulons
mettre en place le système s'éloigne ne
sut et qu'on appelle un système
notionnel qui est très individualisé et
notamment dans le calcul de l'espérance
de vie
prix et qui s'appuie sur beaucoup de
systèmes par capitalisation et le
système allemand est un régime il ya un
régime de base qui ressemble au régime
de base tel que nous le connaissons en
france mais le système complémentaire
est un système complémentaire par
entreprise donc c'est pas parce que
c'est par point que c'est la même chose
que nous voulons proposer
nous ne voulons proposer un régime de
base et complémentaires fusionnée sera
plus de sens en tant que telle base et
complémentaires et qui soit par
répartition sur l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et pas par entreprise parce
que qui dit entreprises dit aussi
parfois difficultés de certaines
entreprises et certaines entreprises qui
n'aborde pas dans ces cas là
le système et puis sur la prise en
compte du six amendements posée par par
les républicains nous verrons les
spécificités quand nous intégrerons
métier par métier corporation par
corporation des savoirs ce ministre
merci monsieur le président
effectivement le commissaire jean paul
delevoye avec d'ailleurs des instruments
de parlementaires de tous bords s'est
rendu en italie en allemagne en suède
rapporteur voulien vous a expliqué je
pense à très bien renseignés la
représentation nationale sur les
différences réelles et incontestable
objectivement d'ailleurs je déjà dit je
pense dans une réponse à madame la
députée faucillon de votre groupe qu'il
suffisait d'aller le site du sénat et de
le lire l'information qui est public qui
est l'analyse faite par le sénat
notamment du modèle suédois et qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce que nous proposons
donc objectivement ce débat ne devrait
pas avoir lieu puisque tout le monde
peut vérifier que ces cradi calment
différent de ce que nous proposons sauf
à vouloir encore une fois s'enfermer
dans de longues palabres ici pour éviter
d'aller sur le fond de s'intéresser à la
vraie vie des français /
la question qui a été posée par le
président eric woerth je moi je suis
toujours très très soucieux est très
curieux de ce qui a été fait avant que
nous soyons en responsabilité ce qui m'a
amené d'ailleurs à lire et je les fais
tout à l'heure avec intérêt les
préambules où les articles 1er des lois
de 2010 et 2014 pour se féliciter que
tout le monde souhaitait que le principe
d'équité
quelle que soit sa déclinaison soient
présents dans la loi et ils virent que
effectivement que j'ai prises envers ce
projet pareil j'ai regardé comment vous
aviez proposé de faire en 2010 pour
faire progresser faire converger les
âges de départ notamment de la sncf
faire un âge qui n'était pas l'âge légal
à l'époque puisqu'il ne s'agissait que
de le faire progresser de 2 ans vous
aviez choisi un modèle que j'ai repris à
mon compte celui de faire progresser les
âges d'un trimestre par an moi je trouve
que c'était une très bonne méthode sauf
que vous vous l'aviez fait pour deux ans
et nous nous allons faire pour dix ans
et donc évidemment c'est pas tout à fait
la même ampleur et c'est pas tout à fait
la même ambition avis défavorable
monsieur le président merci monsieur
lausanne ah oui merci merci monsieur le
président moi je voudrais revenir sur ce
débat entre l'égalité et l'équité parce
que je trouve que derrière il ya des
conceptions de notre société très
importante
alors je voudrais vous lire l'égalité
c'est la qualité de ce qui est égale
constant uniforme régularité donc
uniformément je rebondis là dessus parce
que c'est bien la conception de la
société que vous avez vous voulez que
nous ayons une société uniforme sans
saveur sans odeur nous notre conception
de la société
c'est d'avoir une société équitable
donc vous avez un choix qui est le vôtre
qui est votre idéologie nous nous avons
un chemin une vision merci madame autant
oui messieurs président c'est un rappel
au règlement sur basé sur la tique 52
alinéa 1
vous m'avez interpellé je le comprends
parce que je prenais une photo habitude
que je n'ai pas puisque il me semblait
qu'il était interdit de prendre des
photos dans notre hémicycle or il se
trouve que hier ou avant-hier une photo
a été prise de mon collègue françois
ruffin et on nous a dit qu'en fait
c'était autorisé donc c'était juste pour
demander au président qu'est ce qui est
réellement de mise et m'assurer qu'il
n'y avait pas deux poids deux mesures
puisque cette photo a bien été prise de
mon collègue françoise y françois je
parle de l'hémicycle monsieur bacheliers
mais si vous voulez on reparle des rosie
quand vous voulez mais là il se trouve
que je parle d'une photo qui a été fait
par un une des collègues de votre groupe
qui a été mis sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui met en cause mon collègue françois
ruffin donc je voudrais savoir quelle
est la règle véritable et à ce moment là
on nous a dit non ce n'est pas interdit
de prendre des photos alors on a tous
été un peu étonné puisque il nous
semblait que c'était interdit donc
quelle est la règle et peut-elle être
appliquée à égalité dans cet hémicycle
tu vends ma soeur est bien ce que j'ai
eu l'occasion de le rappeler plusieurs
fois qu'on prend conférence des
présidents est compris dans un courrier
que j'avais adressé à chacune chacun
d'entre vous lorsque vous m'avez fait
l'honneur de mme élire à la présidence
de l'assemblée nationale
je souhaite que cette pratique soit
proscrite et à la dernière réunion de la
conférence des présidents
d'ailleurs plusieurs collègues
participants ont estimé que justement il
y avait parfois des discussions
informelles qui se faisait entre les uns
ou les autres et que lorsque cela
donnait lieu à des images et ensuite
interprétation polémique sur twitter
c'est est inconvenant donc ma position
est de dire que c'est proscrit tout
comme il est proscrit de venir vous
savez avec des gros sacs avec des choses
comme ça je vous avais dit à l'époque
que notre hémicycle n'était ni un campus
bien camping voilà vous des portes et
des signes vestimentaires le type
commerciaux etc tout ça a été écrit vaut
toujours
voilà monsieur avait demandé la parole
ensuite monsieur dharréville oui merci
monsieur le président moi je vous
propose de revenir au fond parce que
c'est toujours un peu dangereux avec un
texte confus d'avoir un débat confus
sans tomber avec un texte chaotique dans
un débat chaotique mais là si on revient
au fond
et qu'on regarde cet alinéa 5
l'amendement de monsieur jumelles
propose de rajouter dans le respect des
spécificités des métiers et des
suggestions de service public moi je
trouve que ça correspond totalement à la
définition d'une d'une réforme juste des
retraites et l'amendement de notre
collègue marc lefur propose le
sous-amendement propose de rajouter
notamment pour celles liées à l'exercice
de fonctions régaliennes et de sécurité
et là nous pensons tous à nos militaires
à nos policiers à nos gendarmes à nos
pompiers est donc là je trouve que c'est
un peu dommage sur le rapporteur qu'on
ne puisse pas évoqué lorsqu'on définit
cet objectif d'équité qu'on puisse bien
préciser que c'est les mêmes droits mais
pas les mêmes droits de manière bête
c'est en tenant compte de ses
spécificités et là on est dans l'équité
pas dans l'égalité bête et je crois que
si on veut une réforme juste si on veut
un système de retraite équitable
il faut pouvoir établir dès ses premiers
articles
un objectif qui soit à la fois juste et
équitable c'est le sens de la rédaction
de ces amendements que je soutiens
pleinement
merci mme chaudhary ville
oui merci monsieur le président et j'ai
l'impression parfois incertain dos de
nos collègues ont beaucoup de vision
effectivement sur ce texte il voit des
choses en tout cas que nous nous nous
n'y voyons pas là monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre on vous propose
quelque chose d'assez simple en fait
atteint c'est même peut-être quelque
chose que vous mettez en oeuvre dans ce
texte
c'est à dire nous proposons d'inclure
que chaque euro cotisé d'ordonner des
droits pour tous dans le respect des
spécificités des métiers et des
suggestions de service public ça nous
semble être une formule tout à fait
acceptable que pour partie vous êtes
obligé de mettre en oeuvre avec les
multiples exceptions vous avez annoncé
au fur et à mesure des mobilisations
mais voilà comment comment imaginer
qu'on ne souhaite pas effectivement
tenir compte de la particularité de la
vie active de nos concitoyens deux de
nos concitoyens moi j'ai en tête les
ouvriers métallurgistes de la zone
industrielle de fos sur mer chez moi qui
respire pour beaucoup et bien des des
émissions polluantes
avec parfois des conditions de travail
dans la chaleur importante
il est absolument indispensable que tout
ça soit soient prises en compte je pense
que personne ici ne peut ne peut le nier
mais nous voyons qu'ils aient un certain
nombre de métiers avec des spécificités
il ya un certain nombre dans la fonction
publique de sujétion particulière qui
impliquent un certain nombre de règles
tout au long de sa vie active qui voilà
obligée sans doute à une prise en compte
au moment de la liquidation de la
retraite et donc pour la constitution
des droits il faut il faut en tenir
compte sérieusement ne vois pas en quoi
ce que nous avons proposé la pose
problème si je le vois en réalité c'est
que ça sam et noir sur blanc
sa couche noir sur blanc l'idée que
votre principe ne tient pas la route
c'est à chaque euro cotisé donne les
mêmes droits
ça ne marche pas mais bon je pense que
au stade où nous en sommes
vous devriez sérieusement lactée parce
que là on est vraiment dans quelque
chose qui ne tombe pas merci chartres
l'émotion mater
décidément on cherche vraiment à
compliquer ce texte
moi je trouve que le terme pour tous est
suffisamment clair pourquoi vous lui en
vouloir alourdir la rédaction de cet
article
1 franchement alors est ce que c'est de
la posture ce que c'est une forme de
malhonnêteté intellectuelle je sais pas
mais je j'avoue que je suis sidéré
sidéré par rajouter ces mots vous
rendrez un texte complètement illisible
alors le prétexte on l'a compris moi ça
fait maintenant après la commission
spéciale après plus de presque une
semaine passée dans cet hémicycle sur ce
sujet on veut ralentir le débat dont
acte
et franchement franchement est-ce que
comment vous arrivez à tenir avec des
arguments aussi fallacieux d'un moteur
et ensuite nous voterons oui mon cher
collègue ce ne sont pas des éléments
fallacieux qui sont introduits ce sont
simplement des précisions qui vise à
prévenir ce qu'il y a ensuite dans le
texte c'est à dire un alignement un
alignement du régime total sur les
normes du privé c'est ça que vous êtes
en train de faire et vous le savez le
taux de remplacement pour les
fonctionnaires dans votre système va
chuter de 32%
c'est pas une petite histoire de 32%
c'est considérable
donc quand nos collègues communistes
proposent d'introduire qu'on fait
attention dans la loi aux spécificités
de la fonction publique
c'est précisément pour un élément
concret qui vise à ne pas procéder à ce
que vous faites c'est à dire un
démantèlement des spécificités de la
fonction publique voilà donc à bien il
ya bien rooney et c'est là où je
voudrais reprendre par rapport à un
certain nombre de collègues qui depuis
ce matin nous disent ah là là il y en a
marre de discuter des principes parlons
du concret mais il faut bien s'entendre
il y a un écho entre les grands
principes et la réalité concrète et nous
y sommes précisément puisque vos grands
objectifs d'égalité
non pardon d'équité se fracasse sur la
réalité des choses puisque en alignant
tout le monde vous à les appauvrir les
fonctionnaires demain qui seront à la
retraite
j'interviens enfin sur pour interroger à
nouveau le ministre sur le conseil
d'état d'ailleurs vous y faites
référence il est fait référence dans
l'amendement parce que vous ne nous avez
toujours pas répondu
vous nous dites vous avez répondu à
alexis corbière en disant mais non vous
n'avez pas compris mon cher collègue je
termine juste là dessus vous n'avez pas
compris les fonds que les les
enseignants chercheurs nous allons tenir
notre parole en dépit de l'avis du
conseil d'état
donc nous réitérons notre question sur
quoi avez vous tenu compte de l'avis du
conseil d'état
merci madame autun je vais donc mettre
au voir le président en vertu de
l'article 6 alinéa 5
on nous dit que notre un moment est
fallacieux hier qui cherchent à nuire
qui cherchent à tromper perfide en quoi
vouloir substituer aux mots les mêmes
droits pour tous
la notion de droit pur terrien fois sans
rappel règlement est fallacieuse et
erika rosy chaque fois règlement et de
ce que l'appréciation d'un propos ne
convient pas à des orateurs mais on peut
passer notre temps ça je ne vois pas ce
qu'ils font de ce rappel au règlement ce
qui fonde ce rappel au règlement oui
c'est que c'est de considérer que notre
amendement n'est pas fallacieux qu'il
est fondé il ya un an
merci monsieur jumelles je vous remercie
mais si chaque fois que quelqu'un prenne
un adjectif sur le propos de l'autre
appel règlement croyez-moi ce ça devient
tout à fait abusif est totalement
infondé je mets donc qu'on voit le
sous-amendement 40,205 a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur du
gouvernement qui pour qui et contre il
n'est pas adoptée je m'en suis tôt voire
amendement 25 1617 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du rapporteur et du
gouvernement qui est pour ses jumelles
vous êtes pour votre amendement
j'imagine qui est pour et qui est contre
il n'est pas adoptée dans la meynard il
est défendu très bien
[Musique]
bonjour chers collègues nous en sommes à
l'avis du rapporteur je crois bonjour
monsieur le président est défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais défavorables
je vous remercie nous passons donc
directement au vote sur cet amendement
1040 pendant 143 1 00 43 double avis
défavorable et pour qui et contre il est
donc rejeté
nous passons aux amendements 25,48 est
identique qui défend monsieur vélo c'est
vous qui défendez le 25 48
oui merci
c'est un amendement qui des ch'ti qui
est destiné à insérer la notion
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé dans
le projet de loi
c'est une proposition inspirée d'un
amendement de 2013 de monsieur le
ministre vers en monsieur le président
de l'assemblée nationale ferrand qui on
avait fait la suggestion et je vais
trouver finalement assez assez
intéressante et est susceptible de
susciter l'adhésion de la majorité à
laquelle ils appartiennent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je vous remercie nous avons ensuite une
série de dix sept amendements identiques
qui le défend les 23 160 est identique
qui les défend à lamotte ans vous êtes
non défendu nous en sommes aux 23 160
il est effectivement pas sur l'écran
dans le buzz
il est dans mon dossier mais pas sur
l'écran voilà il ya 17 amendements
identiques de la france soumise
on défend pas souligner monsieur
solignac d'abord on vient revient de
défendre l'amendement 21 25 48 qui a été
défendu par monsieur vélo qui était
signé par monsieur solignac nous en
sommes donc au 17 amendements identiques
qui sont les 23 160 est identique alors
allez-y
oui donc c'est un amendement qui vise à
prendre en compte l'âge d'espérance de
vie en bonne santé
aujourd'hui il est de 63 ans les lâches
déquilibre tel qu'il a été défini dans
l'étude d'impact et de 65 ans et même le
conseil d'état a expliqué que cet âge d'
équilibre de 65 ans avait vocation à
augmenter et donc ce qui était un des
éléments qui disait que l'étude d'impact
était était lacunaire au minimum donc la
question qui se pose à partir du moment
où vous assumez de faire travailler les
gens jusqu'à 65 66 67 ans alors que
l'âge moyen d'espérance de vie est de 63
ans et qu'elle est encore plus faible
pour les ouvriers qui sont soumis à des
conditions de travail plus dures que la
moyenne
eh bien vous accepter l'idée de faire
travailler des gens en mauvaise santé
c'est à dire que les gens quand ils vont
partir en retraite seront en mauvaise
santé et pire qu'elle est l'employeur
qui va embaucher quelqu'un qui est en
mauvaise santé il n'y en aura pas et
donc que nous allons augmenter le
chômage de cette période là dont vous
aloi appauvrir les caisses de
de l'allocation chômage pour remplir les
caisses trop de la retraite c'est un jeu
de bonneteau où on prend d'un côté on
donne de l'autre et au final ceux qui
trinquent ce sont les français qui
devront travailler plus longtemps en
mauvaise santé et qui ne pourront même
pas bénéficier de la retraite en bonne
santé
vous condamnez les gens en fait à
travailler jusqu à la mort ou au mieux à
l'hôpital même si nous plaçons sous
amendement le 42 200 c'est d'arriver où
monsieur wulfranc 42 cents celui qui
changent les mots au regard de paru
égard à ses justes pour le situer oui
pour le situer allez-y mais je ne situe
surtout dans la question qui vient
d'être soulevée ça vous n'y couperez pas
vous n'y couperez pas un cette référence
à l'âge de départ en bonne santé
moi je fais pas de spécificité sur ma
circonscription et sur les vôtres sauf
sauf que quand vous êtes face
effectivement aux populations qui sont
affectés lourdement par leurs conditions
de travail que ce soit effectivement les
populations d'ouvriers d'agriculteurs
d'employés
l'employé du de petits employés du
tertiaire du tertiaire normal hein
eh bien vous êtes en situation de
vérifier sur le terrain comment la non
prise en compte de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé dans le cadre d'un
basculement majeur de 62 à 65 et demain
67 ans est au coeur de la négation même
qui est majoritaire de votre réforme il
ya un basculement qui va bien au delà du
texte
elle nie ce basculement dans les têtes
il est vécue de manière tripale
et ça vous n'y échappera pas vous n'y
échapperez pas on est là dans un débat
de société et d'un débat classe car il
on arrive là au coeur de ce que les
français aujourd'hui vous disent on veut
profiter de notre retraite
un minimum tranquillement et en bonne
santé
je vous remercie est ce que vous
considérez que c'est également la
défense du 40,201 celui nancy un autre
donc allez-y monsieur dharréville merci
monsieur le président ce que vous êtes
en train de faire c'est de voler aux
françaises et aux français leurs
meilleures années de retraite c'est à ça
que va aboutir le projet que vous êtes
en train de mettre en place
en reculant toujours plus génération
après génération l'âge de départ à la
retraite en donnant finalement le choix
aux gens entre partir en bonne santé
avec une retraite des côtés ou attendre
patienter s'épuiser au travail afin
d'attendre l'âge le fameux âge soit
disant d' équilibre c'est ça la vérité
de votre projet de loi et donc je crois
qu'il ya une violence symbolique qui est
extrêmement puissante dans la décision
vous êtes en train de prendre c'est de
repousser
d'ores et déjà la jeu de départ à la
retraite au-delà de l'âge d'espérance de
vie en bonne santé
ça je crois que il faut bien mesurer la
violence symbolique et la violence
réelle parce que ça va s'appliquer dans
les vies de cette mesure que vous êtes
en train d'imposer donc inscrire dans le
texte de manière précise la prise en
compte c'est ce que propose cet
amendement la prise en compte de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé dans
les principes généraux nous semble
fondamental je vous remercie donc là
c'était bien le 40,201 nous passons donc
aux 42 cents 2 est-ce qu'il est défendu
au pain au regard de oui il est défendu
40 253 ce qu'il est défendu
je remercie 40 255
également je vous remercie quarante 233
toujours dans la même logique
pardon 40,205 133 au regard par en
considération qu'il défend oui oui merci
c'est un débat tout à fait fondamental
parce que si on augmente la durée au
travail de personnel qui ont des métiers
si pénible que leur espérance de vie et
en bonne santé était évidemment très
différente de la moyenne des français
vous comprenez bien que on va finir par
mourir au travail et je veux prendre
l'exemple des égoutiers parce que les
égoutiers ont une espérance de vie
inférieure de 17 ans à la moyenne de 17
ans est considérable or si on applique
votre régime
demain osé bouttier qui n'ont pas de
spécificité reconnu dans la loi
actuellement
eh bien ils vont travailler dix ans de
plus dix ans de plus c'est à dire qu'ils
vont arriver à un âge où déjà une partie
d'entre eux malheureusement décède
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'à travers cet
exemple des égoutiers la question qu'on
a envie de vous poser c'est que dans
votre espèce d'idée d'équité et de 1
euro cotisé égal 1 euro à la fin et je
ne sais quoi on ne voit plus du tout
comment vont être pris en considération
la pénibilité des métiers la dureté
spécifique pour certaines catégories de
la population et c'est le grand oublié
d'une certaine manière de cette loi
c'est l'enjeu de la pénibilité et
peut-être qu'il y a des choses qui vont
être demain inscrits par les ordonnances
prises par le gouvernement
mais aujourd'hui dans la loi on ne voit
aucune protection pour des catégories de
population qui vont devoir demain
travailler beaucoup beaucoup plus
longtemps au prix peut-être de leur vie
ou en tout cas de l'impossibilité de
profiter de la retraite en bonne santé
je vous remercie nous passons
sous-amendement 42 154 qui le défend
monsieur l'arrivée merci
monsieur le président dans le dans le
débat on a parfois entendu l'idée que en
réalité il y avait une demande massive
dans la société de pouvoir travailler
plus longtemps et qu'il y avait une
forme d'esprit totalitaire à vouloir
instaurer un âge légal de départ à la
retraite
moi ce que je rencontre enfin je sais
pas comment on peut dire des choses
comme ça de manière sérieuse
enfin nous l'avons entendu moi ce que
j'entends beaucoup autour de moi sont
des femmes des hommes qui attendent cet
âge de départ à la retraite au bout
d'une vie de travail la possibilité
d'être enfin libérée du travail prescrit
de pouvoir faire un peu plus ce que l'on
veut de son existence
je crois que c'était vraiment un
marqueur de civilisation que nous devons
garantir et donc reculer l'âge de départ
au delà de l'âge d'espérance de vie en
bonne santé et bien du coup et une
entrave évidemment est une atteinte
forte à ce droit tels que nous voulons
l'instaurer je pense à des infirmières
des aides soignantes à des ouvriers dans
l'espérance de vie est bien moindre que
celle des cadres qui a des employés qui
autour de moi dans ma circonscription
dans les échanges que nous avons eus les
réunions publiques que nous avons
obtenus sur les retraites sont venus me
dire ses préoccupations cette idée que
je pourrais pas y arriver à l'âge qui
mais prescrits auquel on veut que je
parte je ne pourrais pas y arriver c'est
au dessus de mes forces je crois qu'il
faut vraiment arrêter cet appel à la
productivité toujours à augmenter de
l'humain il faut revenir à la réalité et
mieux respecter les femmes et les hommes
je vous remercie avant de passer aux à
vivre et vous informer que le groupe
gauche démocrate et républicaine la
saisie de scrutin public sur les
amendements de 25 48 est identique 42
cents soit 102 et 40 253 monsieur le
rapporteur il faudrait votre avis
merci monsieur le président voilà
typiquement un sujet qui devrait faire
l'objet d'un débat de fond qui sera
d'ailleurs prévue à l'article 10 et
quand je regarde mon travail de
parlementaire dont je regarde les
sous-amendement donc vous proposer à la
place de oro gars 2 vous prêts vous
proposez eu égard à ou alors sur un
autre sous amendement afin de prendre en
compte
ou alors un autre sous amendement en
considérant ou alors en prennent mans
pleinement compte en prenant en compte
en considération etc etc donc à la place
du débat de fond qui est nécessaire sur
cette question sur cette question
d'espérance de vie re vous faites un
débat de forme donc défavorable
monsieur le ministre
oui bah attendez on va prendre l'avis du
ministre et puis après merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés nous avons déjà
débattus à au moins deux reprises de
façon extrêmement conséquente je pense
que pendant plus d'une heure de ce sujet
il a déjà été débattu très largement je
me souviens parfaitement d'ailleurs des
interventions du président un président
eric woerth sur ce sujet donc vous
revenez avec le même sujet on est
toujours dans les principes généraux
vous recommencez vous n'avez vraiment
pas envie d'aller discuter du fond du
projet c'est vraiment regrettable avis
défavorable g président je vous remercie
donc nous avons à plusieurs demandes de
prise de parole dans l'ordre monsieur
corbières
monsieur vélo oui bon on est un peu déçu
de la réponse que vient de faire le
rapporteur et monsieur le ministre
tout à l'heure on a eu un débat que moi
je trouve important sur équité et
égalité
vous avez dit on n'est pas d'accord mais
que pour voulait quitter juste ans était
selon les besoins on vous dit tout ça
manque
l'aspect normatif c'est flou mais l'asse
l'occasion précisément de rentrer dans
le cadre est d'aller dans votre sens il
ya des inégalités flagrantes dans les
carrières
de chez nos concitoyens des inégalités
d'espérance de vie significative vous ne
l'ignorez pas vous le savez je ne
polémique pas avec vous là dessus
mettons le dans la loi ça nous rassurer
et à travers nos sans doute beaucoup de
français qui sont assez inquiet et la
non seul coup vous ne répondait plus sur
le fond vous nous dites vous voulez
rentrer dans le détail voilà pourquoi
j'ai vaincu tous honnêtement cette
manière de faire j'ai bien compris qu'à
une stratégie qui vise sans nous dans
les prochains jours dire que nous ne
pouvons pas débattre et sans doute qu'il
va y avoir lundi un coup de théâtre
s'appuyant sur le fait notre
méticulosité c'est votre choix
mais là on rentre là on veut discuter
sur le fond de vous dire oui mais non
mandat on a bien compris
mais attendez présidence je viens
d'entendre laquelle clown
non mais on peut éviter de se parler
comme ça président
franchement allez-y monsieur car bien
non mais c'est s'il vous plaît je l'aï
président fonctionnement bien non mais
j'aimerais qui est un peu un peu de
dignité
je me fais insulter je n'ai pas entendu
l'un sur vous pour dit mais moi je n'ai
entendu on l'a entendu très bien
d'accord écoutez il est monsieur combien
de bons mais c'est peut-être pas moi
qu'il faut s'adresser se mettre aux
collègues puisque moi je vais bien
non mais évidemment je vous invite au
respect dans cette assemblée les
insultes n'ont absolument pas le regard
triste
merci qu'elle soit dans soyons clair
monsieur corbières continuer votre
intervention est ce la peine de
l'interrompre à chaque achat qu pardon
et c'est une semaine de l'interrompent
sens à la fin que tu en es préhension de
l'hémicycle parce que sinon on sait dans
les deux sens et donc je vous rappelle
que tout autour d'arras tous les cas
parler d'argent
la qualité du débat je l'invite mes
collègues à écouter monsieur corbières
vous avez la parole allez-y donc je
reviens sur le fait que nous avons là
quelque chose de très important et la
mer dont vous refusez de vouloir mettre
dans la loi sur la base des principes
premiers de votre loi quelque chose qui
est une évidence montre quand même la
grande inquiétude légitime que nous
avons et la manière en plus dans le
rapporteur et le ministre ne veulent
même pas en discuter et en en balayant
les choses franchement démontrent d'une
certaine légèreté est bon nous le
regrettons une fois de plus les français
jugeront monsieur vélo moi je regrette
que plutôt qu'une réponse sur le fond on
ait eu du rapporteur
une explication de linguistique ou de ou
de grammaire ça mérite quand même un
débat un débat plus approfondi surtout
que c'était un amendement du ministre
véran et du président ferrand donc je
pensais que on aurait droit à un peu
plus de considération dans la discussion
que nous avons eue que nous avons eu
effectivement tout à l'heure à des
arguments c'est de dire mais le
l'indicateur d'espérance de vie en bonne
santé n'est pas bien établies etc
mais je dis qu'à cela ne tienne puisque
vous aimez créer des indicateurs et même
fonder une partie de votre réforme sur
des indicateurs qui n'existe pas et bien
prenez le parti de prendre au sérieux
cette notion d'espérance de vie en bonne
santé est de consolider
selon ce que vous considérez comme
solides
cet indicateur il ya quand même 13 ans
d'espérance de différences d'espérance
de vie entre les 5 % de français les
plus riches et 5 % de français puis des
plus pauvres il ya dix sept ans
d'espérance de vie en moins pour les
égoutiers par rapport à la moyenne
nationale et votre système
eh bien avec cet âge pivot il est
extrêmement injuste puisque quand on
aura commencé tôt à travailler
eh bien on aura une décote ou alors il
faudra travailler plus longtemps et donc
nous on revendique une espérance de vie
en bonne santé une vraie égalité devant
le temps que l'on passe à la retraite f
ski et puis monsieur martin
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je suis assez des ventes au
cours de ces débats mais je suis thézan
parce que je vous écoute tous et j'ai
entendu tant d'arguments intéressant qui
méritent d'être débattus que ce soit au
fond ou juridiquement tant de sujets qui
nous touchent tous que je suis vraiment
déçu qu'il ne soit pas évoquée au bon
article
je reconnais qu'en tant que législateur
jeu reconnaît humblement qu'en tant que
législateur je suis assez frustré et je
ne désespère pas d'aborder tous ces
sujets très fort qui doivent être
débattues dans les heures qui viennent
et conformément à la procédure
parlementaire qui est la nôtre sans
chercher à l'utiliser à des fins qui
sont au final assez contraire aux
intérêts de nos concitoyens qu'ils
attendent de nous une discussion très
nourris sur ce sujet très fort je
remercie tous remerciés
[Applaudissements]
monsieur martin vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ce débat
peut donner l'impression d'être
chaotique parce que effectivement on
mélange tout les notions et notions
importantes qui devraient venir en
discussion aux articles suivants et qui
sont propulsés au tout début de ce
premier article sur l'espérance de vie
sur le fond y at il un critère formelle
qui peut être appliquée à chaque
individu
évidemment non donc nous devons ne pas
mélanger ces deux débats très important
celui de l'âge de leur attrait celui de
l'espérance de vie
l'espérance de vie l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie doit être améliorée
par des mesures de santé publique de
prévention y compris dans les milieux
professionnels avec la médecine du
travail avec les reconversions et c'est
tout le débat de la pénibilité que nous
avons que nous avons prévu à la fois
sous forme d'amendement et dans le texte
il y à des avancées considérables sur la
pénibilité venansault sur le fond de la
pénibilité très rapidement mais cessons
de perdre notre temps avec des sous
amendements rédactionnels qui ne sont
que de la forme et rien sur le fond
monsieur le franc
[Applaudissements]
oui je ne peux quand même sur ce débat
m'empêcher de lire de relire sans doute
mais de lire aux français qui nous
écoutent le texte de l'amendement de nos
collègues socialistes ils méritent
d'être lus au niveau de ses motifs alors
accordé parce que moi puis le truc ça
fait deux mais voilà le présent
amendement des députés socialistes et
apparentés vise à améliorer la sincérité
du projet de loi fortement mise en doute
par l'avis rendu par le conseil d'état
ainsi le gouvernement fixe au système
universel un objectif d'équité
assis sur le principe que chaque euro
cotisé ouvre les mêmes droits or si le
sur engage une importante convergence
des assiettes et taux de cotisation des
différentes catégories d'assurés il ne
corrige pas l'inégalité central de notre
système de retraite
l'importante écarts d'espérance de vie
et notamment d'espérance de vie en bonne
santé à la retraite entre les assurés et
en particulier entre les premiers et
9ème décile de revenus ou entre cadres
et ouvriers pire
écoutez bien si c'est du verbiage
écoutez bien si c'est du rédactionnel en
remodelant les dispositions du 2 de
l'article l 111 2 1 du code de la
sécurité sociale
dans ce nouvel article il fait
disparaître en termes d'équité la prise
en compte de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé qui existe avec lui aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça c'est du verbiage est-ce
que ça ça mérite pas au niveau de cet
article 1er une discussion de fond qui
est fondée
mental pour les françaises et les
français je vous remercie tous les
groupes qui l'ont souhaité ont pu
s'exprimer nous allons donc passer au
scrutin procédé au scrutin j'ai prié de
regagner vos places donc pour la clarté
de nos débats et de nos votes suivez
bien les différents scrutins donc là
nous parlons du 40 200 celui qui
changent les mots au regard des parts eu
égard à il ya un scrutin public je le
mets donc aux voix le 42 cents le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
94 autant 80 d'exprimer majorité à 40,2
pour 9 contre 73
maintenant le 40,201 qui change au
regard de parts afin de prendre en
compte nom de monsieur dharréville nous
le passons au vote le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
90 votants 4 ans exprime majorité à 41
pour 11 contre 69 nous passons
maintenant aux 40 et 40 202 de monsieur
jumelles celui qui change au regard des
parts en considérant le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos 94 votes en majorité
à 42 pour 10 contre 72 il est donc
rejeté nous passons maintenant aux 40
253 qui changent le regard de parents
plein en prenant pleinement en compte le
scrutin est ouvert avec plaisir le
scrutin est clos
95 autant majorité à 42 pour 10 contre
72 nous passons maintenant à main levée
cette fois ci je demande de bien suivre
le 42 155 qui change au regard de par
prenant en compte de monsieur
dharréville qui est pour et qui est
contre
je vous remercie nous passons aux 42
centres trentre trois cette fois ci
c'est au regard par en considération et
c'est à main levée qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est rejeté nous passons maintenant
aux 40 254 qui est également à main
levée qui est pour et qui est contre
je vous remercie et cette fois ci nous
passons au vote de l'amendement par
scrutin public 25 48 est identique
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
ouvert on peut pas faire 2 2 on est en
cours du matin on est en cours du vote
donc je vais procéder au vote puisque on
peut plus interrompre le vat une fois
qu'on a lancé le vote
je vous remercie le 25 48 donc le
scrutin est ouvert maintenant il est
clos
95 autant pour 10 contre 75 il est donc
rejeté nous pouvons passer dans
l'amendement suivant
sur le oui très bien je suspends pour
trois minutes seulement cinq minutes
nous suspendons concerne tous
c'est en ses reprises nous passons à
l'amendement 23 852 monsieur pottier
c'est vous qu'il défendrait je vous
remercie
nous sommes sur des sous-amendements le
42 500 2 merci monsieur le président
donc on a déjà beaucoup parlé de
natalité
depuis quelques jours notre système de
retraite est bien basé sur la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
depuis dix ans les politiques familiales
ont été terriblement malmené et
aujourd'hui la natalité est en baisse
puisqu'on a vingt mille naissances de
moins par an il me semble quand même
nécessaire de rappeler qu'une des
origines du déséquilibre de notre
système de retraite est bien
démographique
donc cet amendement de notre collègue le
furent vise à préciser que la réforme
des retraites prenne en compte la
situation des mères de famille la
naissance d'un enfant peut entraîner un
impact fort sur la carrière des parents
le plus souvent de la mer les parents
devraient être soutenues dans le choix
d'élargir leurs familles et de pouvoir
bénéficier grâce à la solidarité
nationale d'un nombre substantiel de
points supplémentaires
compte tenu des perturbations que cela
que cela entraîne dans le parcours
professionnel
je trouve qu'il est quand même très
injuste de parler en pourcentage est
bien équitable et juste si on prend deux
exemples pour le premier enfant une
retraite à 1000 euros 5 pour cent
cinquante euros pour le premier enfant
une retraite à 5000 euros 5 % 250 euros
pour le premier enfant
quel terrible injustice monsieur le
ministre il ya des vrais sujets de fond
qui doivent être vraiment débattu ici
dans cet hémicycle
[Musique]
je vous remercie nous pressons sous un
moment 40 2 j'aurais voulu que quelqu'un
42 0 44 monsieur jumelles l'an oui
monsieur jumelles que le défendre suppl
1 42 0 44 je vous remercie
le 42 0 65 1 il également défendu
monsieur jumelles vous avez la parole
vous connaissez
ce magnifique auteur edouard louis écrit
qui a tué mon père et il explique
qu'avec beaucoup de poésie mais aussi
avec beaucoup de sensibilité que pour un
certain nombre de décideurs politiques
les décisions qu'ils prennent non aucune
aucun impact sur leur vie
dire que quelle que soit la décision
qu'ils prennent ici
leur vie ne va pas se trouver modifiée
ils vont pouvoir continuer à prospérer à
rêver à prendre soin des leurs et que
pour un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens il ya des politiques il ya
des politiques qui modifient d'une
manière radicale leur vie et moi je
crois que la réforme qui nous est
proposé dans une sorte de mépris de
classe va plomber la vie de ceux qui ont
le moins va aggraver la situation de la
france qui manque va pénaliser ceux qui
n'ont pas les mêmes points de vie en
bonne santé va aggraver les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes et chez
en tête mois les salariés de mon
territoire
c est ce qu ont pas profité de la
retraite parce que l'amiante les a
laminé en quelques jours ce qui lorsque
je fais le marché le samedi parce que je
ne suis pas ici à défendre leur point de
vue on les visages abîmer les daubes
royer ils portent sur leur corps les
stigmates des politiques libérales que
vous
enfiler comme des perles depuis que
depuis depuis la nuit des temps depuis
que vous êtes aux responsabilités parce
que dès qu'on met la même classe la même
classe non mais vous mais bien sûr vous
êtes réputé les séjours les libéraux
sont responsabilité depuis trop
longtemps et font mal aux vielles pardon
non s'il vous plaît chers collègues ils
sont finir monsieur jumelles je vous
laisse le temps de finir si vous voyez
le type d'individu auquel j'ai à faire
mais je parle de la région et on me
parle du goulag messieurs jumelles vous
avez terminé votre intervention par an
les nôtres étaient dans les camps il y
avait la fierté non mais donc de france
on vient de recevoir de ceux qui vous
remercie monsieur jumelles chômeurs si
un sujet où l on arrête là on va pas
laisser
je remercie donc vous pouvez reprendre
la parole si vous le souhaitez sur la
défense du 42 0 14 qui est l'amendement
le sous-amendement suivant vous avez la
parole monsieur jumelles merci président
de permettra aux marcheurs de retrouver
leurs esprits parce que il n'est pas
acceptable d'entendre des propos comme
j'ai entendu lorsque l'on parle des
réalités sociales des salariés que nous
représentons lorsque l'on est marin
pêcheur on n'a pas les mêmes points de
vie en bonne santé que d'autres
lorsqu'on est décortiqueuses de
coquilles saint jacques
vous voulez parler de femme tient bien
voir les décortiqueuses de coquilles
saint jacques qui commence à travailler
à 4h30 du matin quel que soit le temps
et qui répètent les gestes pour offrir
leur blanc à ceux qui ont les moyens de
se le payer on n'a pas les mêmes vie en
bonne santé
lorsqu'on et rieuse de verre et contrit
les parfums de luxe que vous vous
offrait et qu'on transporte une tonne de
parfum par jour on n'a pas les mêmes
points dit en bonne santé
lorsque banon mais qu'est ce qui se
passe s'il vous plaît j'ai manqué votre
intervention donc je ne suis pas au fait
de il saisit à lézinnes citron vert de
terminer vous en êtes à s'offrir des
parfums comme une insulte jeu je ne vois
pas où résident les insultes
j'espère pour vous que de temps en temps
vous avez la possibilité de vous offrir
des parfums mais n'oubliez jamais que
derrière ses parfums il ya des trieuses
de verre il ya des verriers aux bouchons
et pour un parfum qui coûte 100 euros le
coût de la valeur travail c'est un euro
sur un bain un flacon de soro et que le
reste c'est le fric que font ceux qui
font de l'économie en dormant vous savez
ce que vous avez décidé de câliner
depuis que vous êtes en responsabilité
ce que vous avez décidé de choyer dans
vos différentes dispositions fiscales ce
que vous avez décidé d'épargner à
travers la mauvaise réforme que vous
nous proposez et donc moi je me dois de
faire rentrer cette réalité là ne vous
en déplaise ce matin lorsque nous
parlons de l'égalité homme-femme et que
nous parlons de la pénibilité
vous savez tant qu'on sera là on sera là
pour vous 24 % de pib vient quand tu
veux 24 % de pib dans notre industriel
de 24%
lorsqu'il est de 10% pas si je vais en
parler de l'industrie
alors monsieur le rapporteur rappels au
règlement
messieurs petit je m'excuse rappelle
rapidement toujours surfer personnel si
je refuse les amalgames
vous avez dit nous sur les parfums sur
les gens qui étaient dans les camps vous
dites nous et moi je prends personnel
parce que nous c'est une addition de
personnes je vous demande quand vous
faites des choses comme ça de ne pas
parler à nous parce que nous ne sommes
pas tous les mêmes vous avez dit nous
qui étions dans les camps pour dire que
nous nous y étions pas vous avez dit les
parfums vous l'avez dit
je l' amalgame l'amalgamme c'est une
autre époque et c'est pas nous alors
avant l'avis du rapporteur avant la
ville et monsieur le rapporteur avant
votre avis j'annonce et scrutin public
du groupe socialiste sur l'amendement 23
850 2es du groupe l'est républicain sur
le sous-amendement 42-500 de monsieur le
rapporteur quel est votre avis c'est un
amendement il se demande merci monsieur
le président je me joins à mon collègue
monsieur petit je ne retrouve pas du
tout dans vos propos monsieur jumelles
parce que parce que vous représentez des
pêcheurs parce que vous représentez des
pêcheurs des décortiqueuses de coquilles
saint-jacques très bien mais moi je
représente des agriculteurs et j'ai et
j'ai découvert à mes collègues parce
qu'il ya beaucoup cdéné aux députés qui
sont assistantes sociales qui sont
comptables qui sont chefs d'entreprises
qui sont et qui représente une partie de
la france est et nous nous retrouvons
pas dans vos propos qui m'agresse
vraiment qui me blesse et donc je suis
absolument désolé de ce mode de
fonctionnement je veux faire mon travail
de rapporteur d'aller sur le fond est ce
qu'on va aller sur le fond est ce qu'on
va essayer de trouver des solutions pour
tous pour tous nous toutes nos nos
concitoyens qui ont des petites
retraites qui ont du mal à vivre le bout
bien sûr qu'il va y avoir des situations
pâti comme et travaillons le fond c'est
pour ça que nous avons été élus nous
voulons travailler le fond et nous
voulons pas travailler leur forme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement
monsieur le ministre la vidéo défend le
président je vous remercie alors il ya
plusieurs demandes de prise de parole
monsieur bazin puis madame du monde puis
monsieur jumelles puis monsieur merci
monsieur leurs jambes sur le rapporteur
vous voulez sur le fond mais à chaque
fois
vous oubliez les les amendements ou des
sous-amendements qu'on a pu défendre
madame la présidente de commission
il ya eu un sous-amendement de notre
collègue marc le fur qui a été défendu
qui évoque les mères de famille ce
sous-amendement il n'est pas anodin
il vise à préciser dans les objectifs de
la réforme
en tenant compte de la situation des
mères de famille et cela me semble
judicieux car vous parlez souvent des
femmes grandes gagnantes de la réforme
on n'a pas arrêté de l'entendre
peu des mers qui pourrait pour certaines
être perdante dans le futur système et
ce n'est pas qu'une nuance sémantique
vous multipliez les évocations d'exemple
gagnant mais vous omettez les exemples
des mers perdante
le nouveau dispositif des 5% par enfants
s'affairent s'avère pour nombre de cas
moins favorable que les règles actuelles
notamment avec les durées d'assurance
il s'agit des femmes qui ont validé
moins de 30 ans de service et alors pour
les mères qui vont accueillir trois
enfants ou plus et qui d'ailleurs pour
notre système par répartition vont
permettre d'avoir deux futurs quotidien
la perte elle sera d'une d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle et je trouve dommage
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre que vous ne répondiez pas sûr
sur ce sujet des mères de famille pour
nous il est essentiel
on souhaite préserver les doivent droits
familiaux on y est très attaché au
niveau des républicains je vous remercie
le même du monde merci monsieur le
président hu est une seule rapporteur
c'est pas sérieux quand vous dites on
veut aller sur le fond on ne parle que
de ça quand on parle de l'égalité hommes
femmes
c'est bien ce sont bien des questions de
fond et quand vous nous dites alors que
les femmes touchent une retraite
d'environ 40% inférieure à celle des
hommes
quand vous dites que elles seront les
grandes gagnantes de la réforme nous on
essaye juste de vous démontrer pourquoi
ça n'est pas le cas même si le vrai
enjeu il serait d'ailleurs en amont de
la retraite
évidemment sur l'égalité salariale je
laisse de côté
pourquoi c'est faux pourquoi c'est faux
quand vous dites les grandes gagnantes
seront les femmes
1 parce que des femmes plus exposés aux
carrières incomplètes et donc seront les
premières victimes du système à points
les premières victimes du système à
points puisqu'elles sont les premières
touchées par les temps partiels les
congés parentaux et caetera et demain
les mauvaises années entre guillemets
seront intégrés au lieu des 25 meilleurs
donc ce seront les premières victimes
deuxième argument pourquoi c'est faux
parce que les mères de famille devront
travailler plus longtemps
concernant la maternité le nouveau
système faut le rappeler propose
d'accorder une majoration monétaire au
maire et non pas du temps de cotisation
et donc je vous donne un exemple pour
clarifier les
les choses c'est toujours plus clair une
femme née en 75 ans 1975 qui a commencé
à travailler à 22 ans et qui a eu un
enfant
dans le système actuel elle peut
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
enfin le pourra à 63 ans
soixante cinq mois les huit trimestres
de majoration
on est bien d'accord avec le nouveau
système
elle devra atteint atteindre l'âge
déquilibre de sa génération soit 65 ans
donc elle devra pour partir un taux
plein faire deux ans de plus voilà ce
qu'il ya dans votre système
donc arrêtez de nous bassiner j'allais
dire je cherche un autre mot pour nous
expliquer que ce sont les grands
gagnants c'est faux et on essaye de vous
le démontrer ça c'est du fond monsieur
le rapporteur
merci monsieur jumelles c'est monsieur
jumelles alors dans l'ordre et monsieur
jumelles puis monsieur villefranche puis
monsieur mignola madame autant madame
hautain et madame du bre schirrhein on
ne cesse de parler du fond je rappelle
que le sens de mon intervention c'était
en référence à edward lui est de dire
que lorsqu'une loi était modifiée elle
avait un impact sur la vie réelle des
gens enfin est ce que quelqu'un peut
contester cette réalité objective je
reviens au fond de l'égalité hommes
femmes
lorsque vous décidé d'intégrer dans le
mode de calcul des fonctionnaires la
prime
vous ne pouvez pas faire l'impasse sur
le fait que les femmes dans la fonction
publique d'état hospitalière et
territoriale ont 20% de primes de moins
que les hommes sans compter qu'elles ont
un salaire inférieur et que ce faisant
vous aggravez dans votre mode de calcul
de la retraite par points futur
d'inégalité entre les hommes et les
femmes
est ce que est ce que cela ce n'est pas
une question fondamentale lorsqu on
appréhende le système de retraite
demain lorsque je vous parle des
décortiqueuses de coquilles saint
jacques qui travaillent en moyenne le
temps de la saison coquille c'est à dire
six mois et que les six autres au mois
de l'année elles ont d'une certaine
manière l'obligation d'être en chômage
technique
je vous dis que
votre projet de réforme va aggraver la
situation de ces femmes et ne va pas
prendre en compte leurs éléments de
pénibilité le fait que leur espérance de
vie en bonne santé ne soient pas les
mêmes que les bourgeoise de neuilly est
ce que en disant cela je porte
bajaur est enfin j'imagine que je heurte
un réflexe de classe et qui est le vôtre
et que j'exprime un réflexe de classe
qui est qui est le mien je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'être désagréable avec vous
en disant cela
j'ai simplement le sentiment et je veux
bien vous parlez des agriculteurs chers
collègues sur quoi j'ai mille six cents
agriculteurs dans mon territoire et ils
se sentent floués abandonné et ils
sentent qu'ils ont été leurrés par les
promesses de gascon sur les retraites
agricoles
est-ce qu'en disant cela j'ai
l'impression de ne pas parler des sujets
de fond moi je remercie monsieur voilà
mesdames et messieurs j'entends bien que
lorsqu'on porte un point de vue de faire
les vols mais ça vous plaît pas
nous passons à monsieur wulfranc vous
avez la parole chocolat mais vous voulez
aller au fond mais ça y est vous y être
parce que comme le rappelle comme le
rappelle normalement gens qui m'en a le
secrétaire général de la cgt les sens
bah ouais faut quand même en revenir à
la base votre retraite c'est quoi c'est
tout le monde tout le monde va
travailler plus tard y compris les
métiers pénibles faut quand même revenir
à l'essentiel et cela sur un fond parce
que vous nous dit que la santé au
travail on va travailler etc
ça fait deux ans et demi que vous
arrivez pas à travailler sur la
pénibilité avec les organisations
syndicales
vous avez d'ailleurs mis au tort quatre
références en matière de pénibilité du
travail
et c'est quoi le travail aujourd'hui
c'est quoi le travail aujourd'hui c'est
une pression non seulement sur les corps
qui se renforcent qui se renforce avec
effectivement des politiques patronales
qui eux augmentent la pression sur la
rentabilité au travail mais c'est aussi
là
pression psychologique on vous a pas
entendu sur le procès france télécom
hors dé france télécom aujourd'hui il y
en a des milliers dans le pays y compris
chez les fonctionnaires y compris dans
l'éducation nationale
et ça vous le savez très bien et puis si
on part aussi la question des femmes des
femmes et des hommes
expliquez-nous pourquoi dans le régime
de bonification pour les parents de
familles nombreuses
vous faites passer dans votre réforme
une réduction de la portée de ce
dispositif en abaissant la compensation
à 60 % x du smic contre 100 %
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que ça veut dire au niveau
effectivement de la prise en compte des
hommes et des femmes qui sont parents de
familles nombreuses
je remercie monsieur le président
messieurs là vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président nous partons d'un
amendement sur l'égalité femmes hommes
avec 5 sous-amendement on vient
d'évoquer dans le commentaire
les camps de concentration la prime des
fonctionnaires les flacons de parfum la
lutte des classes france télécom on s'y
perd un peu dire en sachant que si on
veut apporter un certain nombre de
réponses
outre le fait que le cas échéant nous
avons tous préparer des amendements pour
faire progresser les droits familiaux
l'article 44 je rappelle sans même
attendre l'article 44 que nous parlons
de l'égalité hommes femmes à l'alinéa 6
l'alinéa suivant vous êtes en train
d'amendé et de sous-amendé un autre
alinéa pour parler des femmes
en réalité vous n'attendez pas vous ne
vous attendez pas vous ne faites que de
l'obstruction en prétendant parler du
fond et vous vous moquez de nous vous
faites pas de l'obstruction contre la
majorité vous fait de l'obstruction
contre les femmes contre progrès social
contre tout ce qu'on peut dire à nos
concitoyens
arrêtez de vous moquer du monde et vous
voudriez nous faire culpabiliser parce
qu'on parle pas des femmes
on en parle dans l'année l'alinéa
suivant vous vous moquez vous vous
moquez des femmes assument et le
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame autant alors là
en cinq jours
[Musique]
parce qu'il ya quelque chose que je
comprends pas très bien quand mon
collègue jumelles vous parle de la
différence entre la réalité d'une femme
qui vit dans des quartiers bourgeois et
qui n'a pas un métier pénible et une
femme qui est ouvrière dans sa
circonscription
en quoi vous sentez vous insulter je ne
comprends pas c'est une réalité sociale
monsieur messieurs dames c'est une
réalité sociale lauper et moi ce que
j'observe c'est que et dans ce texte est
dans la façon dont vous parlez de la
réalité sociale
il y à un déni des inégalités il y à un
déni des rapports de classe il y à un
déni de la réalité sociale dans ces
mécanismes qui crée des inégalités
profondes votre loi elle va pénaliser
les femmes d'abord parce que les femmes
ont des carrières plus haché quand vous
calculez sur l'ensemble de la carrière
et non plus sur les 25 meilleures années
vous allez pénaliser les femmes que par
ailleurs vos droits familiaux vos droits
familiaux 2 5 % de majoration donne 5
écouté les arguments calmez vous
détendez vous s'il vous plaît sa
collègue
accepter que l'on parle du fond accepter
que l'on parle du fond moi je parlerai
quand vous aurez s'il vous plaît je vous
demande d'écouter l'oratrice est le
minimum de respect qu'on doit à chaque
orateur dans cet hémicycle madame autun
vous avez la parole
oui je redis les arguments carrières
hachées
voilà les femmes aux carrières hachées
quand vous calculez sur les l'ensemble
de la carrière et non plus sur les 25
meilleures années ce sont les femmes qui
ont eu des interruptions de carrière etc
qui vont être les plus pénalisées elles
le sont aussi parce qu'elles ont les
plus bas salaires
et elles le sont elles seront les plus
pénalisées aussi parce que dans la non
prise en compte de la pénibilité vous
avez aujourd'hui des métiers féminins
qui sont très pénibles je pense aux
autres têtes aux hôtesses de caisse qui
ont des troubles musculo musculaire ou
le savez musculo squelettiques qui sont
en grande souffrance quand elles vont
devoir travailler jusqu'à 65 ans 67 ans
je ne sais pas ce que ça donne c'est
effrayant quand vous êtes professeur des
écoles rendez vous compte que ce serait
d'être devant une classe à 65 67 ans
mais de quoi on parle
de quoi on parle quand travaux droits
familiaux et j'espère que vous ne ferez
pas le 49 3 et qu'on arrivera à
l'article 40 la réalité
la réalité sur le cas tu me plais chers
collègues je demandé s'ils voulaient sa
collègue s'il vous plaît chers collègues
calmez-vous chose est sûre calmez-vous
mavs a ajouté ce point parce que les
réponses des ministres ne sont pas
toujours précises là-dessus madame
busards m'avait répondu mais ne vous
inquiétez pas il y à une majoration dès
le premier enfant donc c'est beaucoup
mieux que le système actuel
sauf que le problème auquel oui je
conclus auquel le ministre ne m'a jamais
répondu monde c'est la question de la
majoration qui concerne la durée dans un
système où la durée n'est plus prise en
ce moment c'est le gain d'un an de deux
ans par enfant entier où est-ce qu'ils
passent et bien là c'est sa moins dix
ans par le succès du bruyant
merci monsieur le président alors oui
effectivement de quoi parle-t-on dans
cette réforme
depuis des jours et des jours on entend
décrire un travail noir pessimistes des
années 60 peut-être et du travail des
femmes
bien sûr il ya de la fatigabilité dans
le travail physique psychologique
ça fait plus de 40 ans que je travaille
dans comme soignante dans les hôpitaux
dans les cliniques et en secteur libéral
et les modalités de travail
bien sûr elles ont évolué mais ce que je
constate aussi c'est que dans la
fonction publique contre la retraite
était à 55 ans les personnes partait à
aujourd'hui elle est à 57 des gens
partent à 59
pourquoi parce que effectivement les
niveaux de retraite et bat peut-être
mais aussi parce que les personnes ont
eu des enfants tard ils ont des enfants
à charge
ils ont des parents à charge et que
qu'est-ce qu'ils font après ils vont
travailler à temps partiel dans le privé
ou en libéral où les infirmières
travaillent jusqu'à 65 ans et ne sont
pas moins fatigué que les autres
et qu'est ce que cette réforme père va
permettre la comptabilisation des petits
boulots coffey pendant qu un étudiant la
comptabilisation des congés maternité la
comptabilisation des enfants
le conte pénibilité qui permettra de
partir deux ans plus tôt l'intégration
des primes dans le calcul qui
aujourd'hui nier pas la cessation
progressive d'activité
avec le compte épargne et le cumul
emploi-retraite tout ça c'est la vraie
vie et quand on a travaillé parce que on
est ici sur ces bancs un grand nombre à
connaître la vraie vie de travail 1 au
quotidien et je pense que ce qui
intéresse les personnes aujourd'hui ce
sont ceux qui travaillent et que à 20
ans je pense qu'effectivement la
première préoccupation n'est pas la
retraite mais le premier boulot qu'on va
décrocher qui gardent correspondra le
mieux à ses souhaits alors les leçons
on en a eu mais on en n'a pas à recevoir
de certains bancs je vous remercie
alors monsieur le rapporteur général et
madame la présidente de la commission
vous avez la parole à l'issue n'est pas
ce qu'on vote oui chers collègues je
voulais intervenir sur ce débat qui est
particulièrement important que nous
avons déjà eu à plusieurs reprises ce
soit en commission ou ici dans
l'hémicycle débat important et je
connais au moins un mérite
chers collègues jumelles c'est de venir
avec des exemples les témoignages de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens qui sont
les vrais exemples
contrairement à sur d'autres bandes où
on entend des cas types fictifs depuis
le début de nos débats ce sont des vrais
témoignages les parcours de vie brisée
des parcours de vie difficile qui touche
tout particulièrement les femmes
je vais juste vous dire que ces exemples
ils me parlent et je pense que à
beaucoup de personnes sur l'ensemble de
ses banques il nous parle que ce soit
des proches ou des concitoyennes que
nous pouvons rencontrer mais quand j'ai
dit l'autre jour que le système actuel
ils étaient faits par des hommes et pour
des hommes celui que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui c'est parce que dans la
réalité effectivement on observe que
dans notre société et dans le système de
retraite qui reflète notre société les
femmes dans la réalité et ce notamment
celles qui sont touchés par les
carrières heurtées les carrières
difficiles qui vont avoir des métiers
ouvriers particulièrement brisant la
réalité d'un système de retraites
aujourd'hui c'est pas le départ à la
retraite à 62 ou 63 ans
encore moins anticipée
un départ à la retraite à 67 ans pour
une pension misère c'est là la réalité
de notre système et c'est cela que nous
voulons que nous voulons corriger que
nous voulons corriger d'abord à travers
la mise en place du système universel
qui permettra à ces femmes qui partent
aujourd'hui à 67 ans de partir deux ou
trois ans plus tôt avec une pension à
taux plein alors ça révolutionnera pas
le quotidien mais ce sera mieux que ce
qui existe aujourd'hui je pense que ça
nous pouvons le saluer après comme notre
collègue sophie panneaux nakhlé nos
collègues de la délégation aux droits
des femmes l'ont souligné
nous devrons avoir une réflexion dans
les années qui viennent nous ne pourrons
pas la voir dans ce texte sur les
retraites sur les critères de pénibilité
qui sont des critères qui ont été pensés
de manière très masculines et des
critères qui ont été peu pris sous des
aspects féminin on ne pourra pas tout
régler ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises
dans ce projet de loi sur le système
universel de retraite mais nous devrons
un jour nous y attaquer pour là aussi
mieux prendre en compte les critères de
pénibilité sur les carrières qui sont
profondément féminine par ailleurs dans
ce système dans ce projet de loi nous
nous attaquons aux inégalités de pension
comme nous le faisons d'ailleurs sur les
inégalités salariales et là quand
j'entendais tout à l'heure une de nos
collègues sur les bancs socialistes qui
nous disait que rien n'est fait qu'il
fallait qu'on prenne enfin des
obligations c'est ce gouvernement et
cette majorité depuis deux ans et demi à
j-2 suez notamment avec la mise en place
d'un index égalité femmes hommes qui a
des contraintes qui oblige les
entreprises dans les trois ans qui
suivent le premier bilan à prendre des
actions pour obtenir l'égalité salariale
et signe atteignent pas eh bien c'est
une sanction d'un pour cent de la masse
salariale alors cela mettra du temps
mais en tout cas nous mettons en place
les dispositifs pour y arriver et nous
faisons pareil sur les retraites quand
nous mettons la majoration de 5 % dès le
premier enfant qui améliorera
considérablement un certain nombre de
pensions après je pensais comme cela l'a
été dit par le président minima que nous
devons
avancez nous devons avancer et sortir de
cette stratégie de sous-amendements qui
ralentit et les débats pour arriver sur
les vrais droits que nous devons
discuter et adopter pour condom
concitoyennes et concitoyens et je pense
notamment dans les droits familiaux aux
avancées que nous obtiendrons quand nous
discuterons de l'amendement sur la
majoration de points pour les mères
isolées qui ici sur ces bancs sera
opposé à ce que nous octroyons une
majoration de points pour les mères
isolées pour les familles monoparentales
qui va s'opposer à l'amendement qui sera
discutée sur une garantie minimale par
rapport à la majoration ou la mise en
place d'un plancher c'est tous ces
droits nouveaux que nous créons et qui
fait que oui comme nous nous sommes
engagés depuis le début dans cette loi
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
est une priorité majeure et doit nous
permettre d'améliorer le quotidien de
nos concitoyennes demain je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la présidente
mes chers collègues on reprend pas
oui il ya de la colère ce matin oui a de
la patience un peu ce matin parce qu'on
peut pas constamment habillé d'un débat
de fond
un débat qui n'en est pas un puisque
vous l'avez vu lorsque nous lisons les
amendements et sous-amendement vous
savez très bien que nous restons sur les
cubes quant au bout de 18 jours nous
sommes à l'article 1er vous imaginez
bien qu'il ya 64 arctique dans notre
travail de parlementaires nous ne sommes
donc pas dans le texte et nous ne sommes
pas dans notre travail de fond dont vous
parlez temps la deuxième chose la
deuxième rizoma colère en tout cas à moi
ce matin mais se jumelle en particulier
c'est ses constantes références à la
vraie vie que nous ne connaîtrions pas
moi je vais vous dire les chaudronniers
qui ont été abîmés par la vie
je les ai pas rencontrés sur un marché
dans un café c'était mon père mois les
femmes qui travaillaient la marée de
boulogne-sur-mer
je n'ai pas rencontré dans un café
c'était ma mère alors vous voyez j'en ai
marre que ses références
j'en ai marre
[Musique]
je vous remercie madame harper
je vous remercie madame à présent nous
allons passer au vote par un scrutin
public en commençant par un scrutin
public vous proposer de gagner vos
places sur le sous-amendement 42 500 qui
a été présenté par madame valentin le
scrutin vous avez gagnez vos places le
scrutin est ouvert
il est clos
sans travaux tant que driver exprimé
pour 20 contre 79 il est rejeté nous
passons aux 42 0 44 qui est à main levée
sous-amendement monsieur barry ville qui
pour qui est contre il est rejeté nous
passons aux 42 0,65 de monsieur jumelles
qui et pour qui compte
il est rejeté au 42 0,41 même vote
j'imagine de monsieur jumelles 42 0 14
me suis jumelles même vote je vous
remercie
nous passons un scrutin public sur le 23
850 2 le scrutin est ouvert
donc nous sommes sur l'amendement le
scrutin est clos
cent de votants 91 exprimer une majorité
à 46 pour 13 contre 78 il est rejeté
nous passons une série d'amendements
identiques avec le 23 51 sur lequel je
saisis par le groupe l'est républicain
d'accord alors attendez je finis ma
phrase et je vous octroie la 66 ans donc
je vais vous en avertir que j saisie sur
les amendements 23 5 131 est identique
par le groupe est républicain d'une
demande de scrutin public que nous
annonçons et nous suspendons pour cinq
minutes
[Musique]
bienvenue
bien
je propose de reprendre nos travaux nous
en sommes à l'amendement 24 531 qui le
défend vous avez la parole du projet
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'un amendement du groupe l'est
républicain qui prévoit un objectif
supplémentaire à votre texte selon
lequel le régime de retraite universel
doit également être égalitaire en
matière d'âge de départ à la retraite de
manière à accélérer la trajectoire
d'alignement de l'âge de départ de
manière plus rapide mais en même temps
on souhaite sanctuariser les
fonctionnaires du régalien et je pense
notamment aux militaires à nos policiers
et nos gendarmes et à nos pompiers qui
assurent la sécurité des français et qui
traverse une période difficile et qui
mérite cette sanctuarisation je vous
remercie amendements identiques monsieur
s'y mirer monsieur signe amendements
identiques
oui un complément de la maman de du
groupe
c'est tellement vise à rappeler que le
nouveau système doit être égalité en
matière d'âge de départ à la retraite
sauf pour les fonctionnaires régalien
notamment les militaires policiers
gendarmes et pompiers qui assurent la
sécurité des français et pour lequel il
faut si non négociable et il faudrait
leur apporter ce qu'il donne
je remercie l 40 387 n'est pas défendu
monsieur le rapporteur quel est votre
avis merci monsieur le président
l'intégration de l'ensemble des assurés
dans le système universel répond
précisément à cet objectif que nous
préférons nommé équité il ne s'agit pas
d'appliquer uniformément les mêmes
règles à tous sans prendre en compte les
sujétions particulières comme vous les
citer notamment sur les fonctions
régaliennes
c'est notamment aussi le cas de l'accès
au départ anticipé ou de la compensation
des interruptions de carrière mais il
s'agit de garantir un traitement
équitable sans distorsion en fonction
des professions d où des métiers donc
défavorable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre le
président d'avis défavorables aussi on a
je crois débat qu il ya deux jours assez
assez longuement du sujet déjà des
fonctions régaliennes dont je crois le
premier alinéa ou deuxième animé abbas
qui devait y avoir beaucoup beaucoup
d'amendements sur ce sujet voilà on y
reviendra
si vous souhaitez dans le texte on en
avait parlé notamment beaucoup pour ce
qui concerne les sapeurs pompiers je
crois avant-hier il faut voir monsieur
le président oui merci monsieur le
président nous ne sommes évidemment pas
très satisfait des réponses du
rapporteur et du ministre et moi je
voudrais soutenir ces amendements que
viennent de défendre excellemment eric
auger dino cinieri nous sommes toujours
dans cet article 1er où la majorité
affirme ses grands objectifs d'équité de
solidarité de garantie le niveau de vie
de liberté de choix de soutenabilité
économique ou de lisibilité
depuis le début de l'examen de ce texte
des aménagements ont été accordés à de
nombreuses professions sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite un objectif
d'égalité en matière d'âge de départ à
la retraite doit donc être affirmiez
c'est l'objet de cet amendement et puis
intégré dans un système universel des
personnes qui sont chargés de préserver
la sécurité des français donc à savoir
les militaires les gendarmes les
policiers les sapeurs pompiers est un
non sens ce sont des personnes qui
interviennent souvent au péril de leur
vie
et rappelons que la sécurité est un
droit fondamental et que c'est une
condition sinequanone des libertés
individuelles et collectives
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement et paraît pas acceptable
puisque effectivement ça reviendrait à
exclure des possibilités de traitement
différencié donc équitable vis-à-vis des
carrières longues vis-à-vis des
travailleurs handicapés vis-à-vis des
personnes qui ont fait l'objet
d'inaptitude d'invalidité donc c'est un
moment il n'y a absolument pas
acceptable en l'état je remercie nous
allons maintenant procéder le scrutin je
mets donc aux voix s'est inscrite en
public je vous rappelle
avaient été annoncées je vous prie de
vous regagnez vos places je mets donc
aux voix l'amendement 24 531 identique
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
n'est on pas qui en fait le seul je te
dérange a pas 90 votants 119 exprimé
majorité à 40 pour 12 contre 67
il est rejeté nous passons à
l'amendement 24 ans et d'amendements et
optiques 24 527 sur lequel je suis saisi
par le groupe est républicain nous
demandent de scrutin public que nous
annonçons qui les défend monsieur projet
vous avez la parole oui c'est un
amendement effectivement du groupe 2 du
groupe est républicain qui prévoit
également un objectif supplémentaire au
projet de réforme et selon lequel le
régime de retraite universel doit
également prendre en compte la
spécificité des professions libérales et
des indépendants il s'agit de marquer
cette spécificité pourrais je porte
notamment la profession d avocat qui est
dans la rue actuellement je vous
remercie monsieur signorile 27 357
identique pour rebondir notamment dans
nos collègues c'est simplement que je
m'endors vise à prendre en compte la
spécificité des professions libérales
sans oublier bien sûr nos avocats et
c'est un objectif de respect des
professions qui valent dans la spéciale
doit être reconnu
je vous remercie le suivant ne me semble
pas défendu sur la porter merci monsieur
le président la lecture de votre
dispositif ma vie telle considéré comme
un amendement d'appel parce que nous
devons nous conformer à l'objectif de
lisibilité de l'intelligibilité de la
loi concrètement juridiquement à quoi
correspondrait un objectif de respect
des professions libérales
pour autant dans vos d'intention et je
pense que nous la partageons il nous
faut être attentif aux professions
libérales
comment professions indépendantes comme
aux salariés et jeu
je crois que vous faisiez
particulièrement écho à ce qui concerne
les avocats nous nous sommes convaincus
de la nécessité de prendre en compte des
spécificités liées aux avocats comme à
chacun puisqu'il ya des spécificités
mais aussi de tenir compte des
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
certaines professions au delà même des
questions de deux retraités et je crois
que sur les avocats il ya il ya une
attention particulière à avoir et que
nous leur devons mais sur le sur le fond
nous pouvons partager votre votre
sensibilité mais sur la forme nous
sommes défavorable à cet amendement
mais si l'ancien ministre ainsi monsieur
le président le sujet des professions
libérales a été abordé à plusieurs
reprises déjà le dire à chaque fois mais
je le dis quand même parce que en vérité
le débat a été posée d'ailleurs par
vauban d'ailleurs je le pense est
relayée par d'autres mais on a déjà
parlé je vous ai dit d'ailleurs tout le
travail préalable qui avait été fait
avec une apl avec les professions
libérales avec leur représentant à la
fois par jean paul delevoye mais
également par mes équipes et moi même
nous en avions parlé aussi autour de la
cg et du débat que nous avions eu je
crois sur le deuxième alinéa sait long
sur le financement
il est c'est important que les
professions libérales soit à la fois
dans ce dispositif universel parce que
elles y ont toute leur place
vous savez que d'ailleurs il ya des
dispositions spécifiques pour leur
permettre d'avoir un conseil où elles
seront représentées dans le projet doit
j'espère que nous pourrons y revenir
assez vite dans
la partie de la gouvernance et au final
le sujet des avocats qui a déjà été
évoquée aussi je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
fait l'objet d'une concertation
approfondie cette concertation
approfondie nous a permis de 2 d'abord
de tomber d'accord sur les aspects
chiffrés qui concerne le fait que la
pension va progresser significativement
pour les avocats dans tous les cas type
que nous avons construit avec des
références qui nous ont été données par
le barreau est aussi de montrer qu'il y
avait une question qui restait pour les
avocats les plus modestes en tout cas
ceux dont le revenu annuel était autour
de 30000 euros puisqu'il y à là à
prendre en compte une évolution du
pourcentage progression de charge autour
de 5%
même avec un effet cg positif et donc
c'est ce sujet que nous travaillons en
ce moment avec leurs représentants et
les représentants des avocats tout en
ayant en tête des points qui était
important pour eux à la fois les
réserves je me suis déjà exprimé sur ce
sujet pour eux comme pour toutes les
professions libérales les réserves
resteront et c'est bien normal à leurs
mains et également pour ce qui est de la
possibilité pour leurs caisses de
fonctionner en délégation de service de
la caisse nationale de retraite
universel
j'ai repris le thème des avocats pour
revenir fois parce que ce sujet-là fait
l'objet d'un travail vraiment avec
toutes les professions libérales et je
pense très franchement avoir passé je
continuerai à le faire avec intérêt la
volonté trouver les solutions du temps
avec leurs représentants
et je crois que on a matière à
construire quelque chose de positif pour
bien sûr j'ai entendu ces j'avais été
invité gt gt députés j'avais été invité
par le président michel picon à
intervenir dans une réunion qu'il
organisait avec l'ensemble des
professions libérales j'ai bien senti ya
quelques mois qu'il y avait des
inquiétudes et la préférence pour les
professions libérales de maintenir
un système peut être limitée à un
plafond qui correspond d'ailleurs
peut-être un peu plus à ce que vous avez
proposé en tous les cas tête que le
président eric woerth ça pue le
développer dans la commission spéciale
mais en même temps ils ont envie d'être
dans la solidarité nationale c'est pas
douché mes parents étaient commerçants
artisans ils ont très envie d'être dans
la représentation nationale ce qu'ils
veulent se rassurer sur la viabilité
économique de leur entreprise et être
assurés sur les réserves qu'ils ont
constitué c'est ce que je m'emploie à
faire et ce que je fais encore ce matin
en prenant un petit peu de temps je vous
remercie monsieur le président je vous
remercie monsieur woerth vous aviez
c'était la parole monsieur verte
merci monsieur le ministre vous nous
dites qu'il ya un travail
d'approfondissement en général on mène
les travaux d'approfondissement avant
l'examen de la loi il ya un truc qui se
fait voilà on travaille on approfondit
on concertent et puis après on présente
un texte au parlement
vous faites le contraire il faut
admettre que vous comprendrez la
difficulté de débattre est probablement
l'aspect chaotique de ce débat est dû à
l'aspect chaotique de la méthode que
vous employez enfin il y avait trois
façons de réforme et je pense au stade
où nous en étions sur le système de
retraite doit être un navet 2 bonne et
une mauvaise
vous avez choisi la mauvaise celle qui
complique le tout celle qui unit faire
sa liste ou et celles qui crée beaucoup
d'exceptions
il y en avait deux autres seul que nous
proposons un plafond de sécurité sociale
en universel et puis pour le reste des
régimes complémentaires une fusion plus
proche public et et privée une
augmentation claire de l'âge des droits
socle sur sur les droits familiaux
enfin bref c'était cet éclair une autre
façon à lui de dire il ya des
indépendants ont certains le proposent
il ya des régimes de public un raging
d'indépendants et il ya un régime de
deux salariés du privé parce que ça
correspond à des catégories différentes
et au fond 3 catégories ça semblerait
assez naturel pour essayer de de mieux
se connecter à la réalité des métiers
vous avez choisi la voie probablement la
plus complexe et sans doute sans doute
avec avec une forme inutilement
complexes ce qui ce qui rend les débats
aujourd'hui ce sont ce qu'ils sont et
vraiment on peut on peut regretter on
peut regretter ce choix mais ça
fonctionne
oui ces amendements concernent donc les
professions libérales et c'est vrai que
c'est chemin faisant que vous avez
changé les règles du jeu en raison de la
colère sociale qui s'est exprimée jusque
dans des secteurs qui habituellement ne
sont pas les premiers à être vent debout
dans la rue je pense en particulier aux
avocats mais on a eu aussi des médecins
libéraux qui se sont manifestés enfin de
très grandes de très nombreuses
professions et là vous entrez dans une
logique de cas par cas avec un règlement
par le biais des ordonnances et une
proposition qui est venu en cours de
route qui consiste à quelque part
amortir le choc
n'est ce pas par une baisse de la de la
csg c'était bien des cotisations
sociales et donc il va impacter le
budget de la sécurité sociale
donc on marche littéralement sur la tête
mais littéralement sur la tête parce que
vous reconnaissez en creux que le
système va être défavorable à une partie
des professions et vous essayer de
compenser voilà c'est ça c'est ça on en
est là mais je veux dire c'est quand
même terrible et on ne sait toujours pas
exactement à quelle sauce les uns et les
autres vont être mangés alors nous
sommes en train de débattre c'est quand
même un vrai problème
ces deux sites parfaitement pas lisible
messieurs turquois je remercie monsieur
castellani merci monsieur le président
un mot pour soutenir cet amendement et
au delà de ça pour me serrer dans ce
débat que les traits que les très riches
coûté l'esprit qui préside à toutes les
formes de ce type ce ne peut être que la
solidarité
l'échangé d'actifs et d'inactifs entre
générations sont le sait sur le fond ce
système ne peut fonctionner que s'il ya
un équilibre entre actifs et nos
objectifs c'est la base nous savons tous
les effets que l'eugénisme en fait sur
ce système que le chômage les effets
dévastateurs qu'il peut avoir que
l'allongement des études c'est plus
positif
bref toute une série de faits qui font
que nous sommes face une créature de
siècle au caire réponse que l'on peut
avoir sur le fond tu es français d'abord
croissance économique mais
qu'elle est on ne peut agir que sur
l'autre terrain jeudi le banc donc les
restes des formes de solidarité ans je
disais hier effort de solidarité entre
les hommes et les femmes
ça a été dit entre ceux dont le salaire
augmente plus rapidement que la moyenne
et les autres entre ceux qui ont un
travail moins difficile et ceux qui ne
peuvent que subir les effets de l'âge
dans leur travail
entre ceux qui brassent des milliards de
produits financiers de dividende de
jetons et puis ce qui laboure la terre
voilà donc face à ça pour résumer on
peut avoir qu'un double que le double
approche dans cette affaire un double
effort ada c'est d'abord un effort
d'assainissement du système depuis un
effort accru de solidarité voix merci
nous allons donc maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre voit les
amendements 24 527 est identique en vous
priant de regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
il est clos
[Musique]
96 d'autant que dans les cars exprimé
pour 21 contre 74 il est rejeté nous
passons une série de dix sept
amendements identiques qui le défend
madame autun c'est vous alors on y va
oui mes chers collègues il s'agit donc
maintenant de l'alinéa 6 dans lequel en
effet on retrouve la question de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
en tout cas la résorption des écarts de
salaire mais pardonnez moi cet objectif
pouvait être également introduit dans
l'alinéa précédent puisque vous étiez
sur un objectif d'équité et qui sait
vous êtes dans un objectif de solidarité
et je redis du coup mon désaccord
si vous aviez mis l'objectif d'égalité à
l'intérieur vous mettez l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes
donc ici mais c'est vous qui êtes dans
la logorrhée enfin c'est incroyable vous
êtes chez parce que vous avez ce matin
mais s'est investie mal quand même s il
vous plaît à chaque collègue
non mais sincèrement s'est excusé moi je
n'ai pas l'habitude de m'exprimer comme
ça dans cet hémicycle mais c'est rare de
vous voir non certes on peut voir aussi
excité et en permanence dès qu'on prend
la parole vous énervez nous traiter de
clown je sais pas quoi enfin je viens
c'est bien là madame vous avez vous on
est sur leurs collègues
écoutons madame autun envie qu'on
continue le débat sur l'égalité
hommes-femmes
je poursuis ce que je suis tout à
l'heure pour prendre cet exemple de
solidarité
donc il y a une dernière question d'un
obstant tout ce que j'ai dit sur les
carrières hachées qui vont être
pénalisés sur l'enjeu de la durée où on
n'a toujours pas de réponse puisque la
majoration ne porte que sur le nombre
d'enfants et non plus sur la durée
il y avait deux levier il n'y en a plus
qu'un comment le premier levier va être
compensée sur la question de la durée je
ne sais pas et j'aimerais bien que le
gouvernement nous apporte des réponses
sur ce point et enfin il ya la question
des pensions de réversion qui ne se
trouvent nulle part dans le texte et le
ministre en commission nous avaient dit
oui c'est vrai madame autant j'avais
posé la question m'avait répondu oh oui
ma cherchez bien vous allez vous amuser
bien sûr allez-y vannes oc alors quand
vous nous dites ça y est c'est pas la
première fois que vous nous fait le coup
c'est ça y est pour dire que oui ça y
est pour dire que ce sera défini par
ordonnance donc il ya plein de choses
qui sont dans le texte à dire vous
pouvez les trouver cris pension de
réversion mais pour nous expliquer que
ce sera décidé par ordonnance donc
arrêtez de nous renvoyer à des articles
qui renvoie à la question qui sera
envoyée aux ordonnances voilà la réalité
de votre loi elle est à trous et on n'en
sait rien je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur
quel est votre avis monsieur le
merci monsieur le président madame
boutin sur ce sujet là toutes les
réponses ont été déjà apporté et seront
abordés dans les articles qu'on sait
qu'ils sont concernés peu plus tard
d'ailleurs vous n'écoutez même pas la
réponse donc preuve du peu d'importance
dont des femmes ou donc j'en conclus que
c'est un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président je trouve comme singulier
madame la députée jeu comme singulier
que vous vouliez amener le débat de
l'égalité femmes hommes de la solidarité
en supprimant s'est aligné il faut il
faut quand même qu'on puisse lire ce que
vous proposez amendement présenté par
madame boutin supprimer l'alinéa 6 alors
qu'elle a nui affiche un objectif de
solidarité au sein de chaque génération
notamment par la résorption des écarts
de retraite entre les femmes et les
hommes etc etc donc vous proposer de
supprimer ça c'est alors donc vous
n'êtes vraiment pas dans le discours de
fond c'est bien on voit bien que vous
n'êtes pas envie de débattre du sujet ou
les supprimer
amélie m'a dit madame autant oui merci
effectivement monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez dit très justement donc madame
autain ou en tout cas son groupe semble
favorable à l'inégalité entre les femmes
et les hommes parce que ce système il
est profondément inégalitaire 60% des
hommes bénéficient aujourd'hui des
droits familiaux
il est profondément inégalitaire parce
que les femmes sont moins bien payés à
-23%
il est profondément inégalitaire parce
que les femmes touchent sont beaucoup
plus concernées que les hommes par les
emplois précaires 85% d'entre elles pour
les temps partiels 78% pour les emplois
non qualifiés
elles sont victimes des carrières
heurtées par le chômage ou alors par des
choix familiaux la grossesse le congé
maternité et cetera elles sont 20 % à
attendre 67 ans pour limiter le rôle
pour liquider leurs droits
et puis je vous rappelle puisque vous
vous intéressez aux droits familiaux
qu'il ya en ce moment une mission
d'information qui travaille sur ces
sujets là sur la politique familiale sur
la natalité et je peux vous le dire
parce que je suis rapporteur que je ne
vois jamais y travailler alors stop à
l'esbrouffe ce que vous faites ça porte
un nom ça s'appelle la posture
[Applaudissements]
madame ou monsieur le ministre qui ne
comprend pas pourquoi les amendements de
suppression des alinéas qui vous
semblent mirifique
je le redis et nous l'avons dit à de
nombreuses reprises dans cet hémicycle
nous proposons des amendements de
suppression parce que ce qui est inscrit
au titre des grands principes ne se
retrouve pas dans le coeur de la loi
donc oui nous combattons la novlangue et
les mensonges qui sont contenus dans les
grands principes qui ne se traduise à
aucun moment par votre texte qui est un
texte d' immense régression sociale qui
tourne le dos à l'égalité qui tout le
dos à la solidarité et qui ne permet
absolument pas d'améliorer notre système
de retraite
quant à l'égalité hommes femmes je vous
remercie de nous faire un panégyrique de
la situation actuelle c'est ça fait 20
ans que je suis une militante féministe
je le connais parfaitement donc qui
propose de rester dans la situation
actuelle
certainement pas de nom mais
certainement pas nous certainement pas
d'eau mais ce que nous disons c'est que
ce qui nous est proposé par leurs
collègues
s'il vous plaît on écoute ma maman est
ainsi nul succès même si vous voulez
qu'on ait des débats c'est bien c'est
goûter donc ce que nous disons c'est que
l'application du régime par points et de
ce qui est contenu globalement dans la
loi va faire régresser concrètement les
pensions des femmes et va les faire
travailler plus longtemps mais bien sûr
que c'est la réalité concrète de votre
loi donc nous n'acceptons pas qu'il y
ait des principes affichés et qu'au
final on se retrouve avec une situation
qui est une situation dégradée
je termine sur le fait je ne suis pas
dans le cadre de travail dont vous
parlez vous savez que nous sommes un
groupe et nous sommes 17 je ne suis pas
la seule féministe de mon groupe et
d'autres me représente
je vous remercie mais attendez on va pas
faire des conversations en privé il ya
d'autres endroits pour les faire j'ai
plusieurs demandes de prise de parole
donc j'ai un rappel au règlement
madame du monde monsieur bazin oui
madame c est le président ça fait
plusieurs fois que monsieur le député
article sans linea 5
ça fait plusieurs fois que monsieur le
député petit et je peux partager se sont
offusqués quand on entend vous dans
l'hémicycle juste derrière son président
de groupe a fait une maladroite
intervention en faisant exactement le
contraire de ce que son collègue venait
de dire en nous accusant en disant vous
êtes contre les femmes
madame la députée limaces vous savez mon
investissement par la commission n'en
attendez attendez attendez j'ai attaqué
personne est en train de défendre des
amendements on attendait on attrape
écoutez je vais vous laisser la parole
mais je vous prie de m'écouter d'abord
l'article sand alinéa 5
ça parle des amendements identiques donc
ça n'a strictement rien à voir avec
votre rappel au règlement
ce que je comprends et je le respecte si
vous faites un rappel règlement surfer
personnel donc un rappel au règlement
sur fait personnel ça peut pas être
l'objet de commenter chacune des
interventions
donc vous pouvez attendre et s'il vous
plaît donc vous pouvez je vous laisse
terminer sur fait personnelle et vous
expliquer en quoi vous ressentez une
agression à titre personnel mais vous ne
relancez pas en ré attaquant sur chacune
des codes des commentaires qui a été
fait s'il vous plaît comme ça on restera
sur des rappels règlement qui ont un
sens vous avez la parole man alors
surfer personnel monsieur le président
je reprenais puisque je disais que
j'étais relativement d'accord avec le
collègue petit c'est pour ça que me
permettait de commencer par ça en disant
que je suis commissaire aux affaires
sociales
il y a beaucoup de rapports et là je
vais être à porter pour la troisième
fois on ne peut pas être dans toutes les
commissions et je prends ce qu'a dit
madame et limaces pour moi et donc faire
entendre que nous ne travaillons pas sur
ces bancs sur mais bon sur notre groupe
faire croire que nous ne travaillons pas
que des sujets nous désintéresse
c'est vraiment mais là on frôle je sais
même pas même qu'ils m'ont tellement c
ces vendeurs je remercie monsieur alors
madame du monde puis monsieur bazin
merci monsieur le président je voulais
rebondir sur la réponse du ministre qui
nous dit l'amendement supprime
l'objectif de solidarité non soyons
sérieux il ya des amendements qui sont
écrit comme ça pour démontrer que
l'objectif affiché à l'article 1 n'est
pas satisfait par ce qui vient après
dans le texte
pourquoi ces amendements sont déposés
parce qu'on a peur
effectivement on craint le parachutage
de ce 49 3 et ce qu'on craint le plus
encore une fois je voulais déjà dit
c'est pas le 49-3 ce sont les effets
délétères de cette réforme pour les
français c'est ça notre obsession et
donc c'est là dessus qu'on essaye
d'argumenter l'objectif de solidarité
pourquoi il n'est pas atteint parce que
déjà l'an dernier il ya eu la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a pénalisé et
qui va pénaliser massivement les
chômeurs avec un seul objectif
l'économie de plus de 3 milliards
d'euros par an et la deuxième lame c'est
ce texte là puisque les chômeurs demain
non indemnisés ne pourront plus acquérir
aucun point pour leur future pension de
retraite
entendez bien ça les chômeurs qui ne
sont pas indemnisés n'attireront pas de
points pour leur retraite alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le cas et d'autre
part ceux qui sont indemnisés
accueilleront demain dans ce système là
moins de points que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
voilà voilà ce qu'on essaye de démontrer
et d'expliquer aux français qu'ils
soient dans les tribunes ou devant leur
télévision donc sincèrement ce n'est pas
la hauteur du débat monsieur le ministre
que de qualifier cet amendement de
suppression l'objectif de solidarité on
essaye juste d'expliquer ce qui est
ensuite dans le texte et qui va
pénaliser par exemple les chômeurs
bien mais c'est pas à votre goût pour
monsieur woerth kaki pour votre groupe
monsieur woerth
mais je me base 1 interviendra après
pour compléter juste un mot sur les
droits familiaux et sur les droits sur
les droits d'aujourd'hui sur les droits
de demain je suis pas sûr que le système
de demain sera plus bénéfique que le
système d'aujourd'hui c'est assez
difficile à démontrer
d'un côté la majoration de durée
d'assurance et la majoration du montant
de la retraite elle se cumule
actuellement au bénéfice de la famille
et plus spécifiquement des maires la
réforme revient à supprimer l'un des
deux dispositifs
il y avait une majoration de durée
d'assurance et il y avait une
augmentation de la de la retraite
les deux est en réalité il y en aura
plus qu'un seul dispositif c'est à dire
une injection de poing à un moment donné
dès le premier enfant
enfin d'un autre côté il ya un peu
d'inégalités là dedans parce que les
points sont proportionnelles est là à la
rémunération que certains auront plus de
points et d'autres d'autres moins comme
il y avait d'ailleurs en termes de
majorations de retraite c'était
proportionnelle mais dans le dispositif
d'aujourd'hui le nombre de trimestres
n'était pas proportionnelle cette fois
ci à la rémunération est donc chacun
étaient traités de la même manière
puisqu'il y avait deux lectures il y
avait deux lectures il ya toujours deux
lectures dans le système il ya l'âge et
puis à la durée de cotisation vous vous
vous tuer la durée de cotisation sauf
pour un certain nombre de points ou de
sujets sur ce sujet-là très
spécifiquement il n'y aura plus de durée
de cotisation il y aura des points et
vous serez uniquement les droits acquis
sont uniquement proportionnels à la
rémunération
je remercie monsieur reverra au temps
dont je voulais dire à notre collègue
que le plus sûr moyen d'aller vers le
49-3 que vous craignez que personne ne
souhaite sur ses bancs c'est
l'obstruction parlementaire c'est
l'étouffement du débat sur le fond
c'est être véritablement sous un nombre
à la fois d'amendements de
sous-amendements et de recours abusif au
règlement permanent et donc il est il
serait temps que l'opposition est vite
d'abuser des droits de l'opposition pour
conduire tout droit tout droit notre
assemblée vers à 49 3 je trouve
incroyable de dire que l'on conduit
l'obstruction de l'assemblée pour éviter
le 49-3 c'est exactement le contraire
et j'aimerais qu'on en vienne vraiment
un débat de fond madame l âme du billet
vert et la parole oui merci madame dubié
elle seule à la parole non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et
même pas
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît chers collègues
reprenons notre calme s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je vais vous laisser la
parole monsieur mélenchon mais j'étais à
la prise de parole de m dubié donc par
courtoisie républicaine je vous propose
qu'on finisse la prise de parole du
modem du billet est juste après il ya
madame dumont qu'à demander un rappel au
règlement et vous même et donc
j'organiserai les débats comme ça pour
pouvoir donner donner faits attendez
attendez attendez attendez à l'envié à
nancy je vous garantis que je laisserai
la parole sur la future madame du bidon
finissons les interventions des groupes
après je prendrai les rappels au
règlement à quai à condition qu'il
s'agisse de rappels au règlement et pas
de discussions à l'infini pour savoir si
un gouvernement va prendre telle ou
telle disposition
donc madame madame dubié sur le fond
d'intervention vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président et avant de
finir mon intervention je vais d'abord
la commande si alors ce que je voulais
je vais expliquer pourquoi effectivement
on peut pas avoir confiance en ce texte
est je viens à certaines à cet alinéa 6
dont l'amendement propose de le
supprimer
je lis dans l'alinéa 6 ainsi que par la
garantie d'une retraite minimale aux
assurés ayant cotisé sur des faibles
revenus
c'est un principe général on pourrait
penser qu'effectivement ça va
s'appliquer à tout le monde mais c'est
pas vrai puisque hier dans nos débats
nous avons compris que pour bénéficier
d'une garantie d'une retraite minimale
il faut remplir des conditions de durée
516 mois et 600 heures par an ou 50
heures par mois d'ailleurs ça c'est un
sujet à nous expliquer si j'ai 50 heures
par mois si c'est une moyenne
ou bien s'il faut effectivement 50
heures par mois
ça aussi c'est un sérieux sujet
donc je voulais prendre cet exemple ou
des au delà de tous les débats sur des
mots ce soit pour montrer que ce qui est
écrit là n'est pas la vérité puisque
après o'neal
on y accole des conditions et donc
forcément ça crée un sentiment de
peut-être pas du prix mais en tout cas
de clarté qui n'est pas affirmé je vous
remercie donc déjà sur le fond je pense
que tous les groupes qui ont souhaité
s'exprimer ont pu s'exprimer donc
maintenant j'ai plusieurs rappels au
règlement dans l'ordre madame du monde
monsieur mélenchon et monsieur woerth
c'est ça non c'est monsieur vélo allez-y
oui ça a changé oui bon écouter oui
merci sur le fondement de l'article sans
alinéa 5 simplement pour pour dire que
le gouvernement fera bien ce qu'il veut
à la fin les chacun en tirera les
conclusions les conclusions qu'il veut
nous avons remarqué que ce qui est dur à
porter
des membres de la majorité il ne
souhaite pas répondre aux questions de
fond que nous essayons de soulever à
l'occasion d'amendements qui se rapporte
aux articles et aux alinéas de 7,2 de
ses titres premier pour ce qui nous
concerne monsieur pour propose ce qui
nous concerne monsieur lors de l'opa
déposée plus d'amendements que la
majorité on est à peu près dans le même
ordre de grandeur d'ailleurs pour un
texte qui n'est pas le nôtre vous l'avez
beaucoup amendé ce que vous lutterez
beaucoup beaucoup d'inconvénients mais
je je je souhaitais vous est adressée je
me permets jeu je permets de m'adresser
de m'adresser à vous voilà ce que je
voulais dire c'est plus ni moins
monsieur mélenchon pour votre rappel au
règlement je fais ça parle alors je
commence par des excuses auprès de vous
monsieur le président parce que j'ai dû
frapper sur mon banc pour attirer votre
attention je regrette le
le geste mais je vous demande mais c'est
de ces absolue sincérité voiliers de
tant de temps à autre de notre côté
parce que comme nous sommes sur le côté
quand on vous l imagine que vous nous
entendez forcément mais c'est très
irritant voilà tout monsieur le
président vous aurez remarqué que votre
groupe n'a pas été absent des débats et
a eu la parole donc croyez moi voyez moi
j'essaye au mieux de l'émission dit
allons-y sur les rassurer bien sûr
monsieur le président que mon groupe a
eu la parole c'est d'autant plus normal
que c'est son droit
alors on attendait pas moins d'eux vous
aussi je veux juste réagir sur le fait
qu'une assemblée a forcément par son
règlement intérieur par le rapport
qu'elle a au gouvernement à étudier dans
chaque circonstance quelle va être sa
manière d'entrer dans le débat
vous nous reprochez de le faire traîner
je l'entends mai et de ne pas parler de
du sujet sur lequel nous sommes en
délibération mais il ne tient qu'au
gouvernement
il ne tient qu'aux rapporteur de
déplacer le débat à un autre article
c'est l'article 95 de notre règlement
intérieur qui permet au gouvernement ou
qui permet aux rapporteurs s'il estime
que la discussion à coude
sous-amendement à changer de sujet de
passer à l'article qu'il estime être
concernés en l'occurrence il s'agirait
de l'article 46 à propos des droits des
femmes sur les questions de la retraite
un mot du gouvernement et la question
est réglée
je finirai en vous disant que nos vieux
le ce qu'a dit notre collègue est très
injuste
nous nous déclencherons le 49-3 mais
c'est très mal connaître la constitution
la constitution prévoit l'article 49-3
non pas pour faire taire l'opposition
non pas parce que le débat dure trop
longtemps mais pour la raison que sa
majorité n'est pas fiable et que le
gouvernement veut la paix
mais non mais vous n'êtes pas fiable
geagea si non non non non non non non
non monsieur le président je vous
remercie monsieur le président on passe
à la suite
alors nous avons encore un rappel au
règlement monsieur woerth non sur la
base de toujours du même article article
sans il ya sorte de halo de mystère qui
flotte dans cette assemblée sur
l'organisation de nos de nos débats
puisque bien souvent des échanges
annonçant l'idée d'un 49 3 les seconds
dix ans les obstructions d'autres disant
n'ya pas obstruction
on est on est là dans l'organisation
même du débat nous on est assez clair on
obstrue rien du tout et chacun peut
faire ce qu'il veut
on ne le fait pas nous sommes évidemment
très intéressé par la discussion sur le
fond on voit que cette discussion sur le
fond elle prend un temps fou parce que
le fond est d'une complexité inouïe donc
sa taille très très complexe donc ça
donne des débats très très complexe donc
des débats très très long et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
ce ne vous posez autant qu'on puisse
l'être à l'emploi évidemment de méthode
qui aboutirait à une rupture brutale de
ce débat après un échec en commission ne
peut pas y avoir un échec en séance
publique ça c'est pas possible et puis
en plus avec un échec en conférence de
financement s'appellerait quand même une
réforme assez mal né il faut bien
l'admettre
donc il ne faut pas ça mais il n'empêche
qu'à ce moment là le gouvernement et la
présidence ont suffisamment d'éléments
la réserve donc pas prête à évoquer tout
à l'heure le président mélenchon peut
être évidemment une manière de faire en
tout cas dispose de beaucoup de
d'éléments pour montrer que l'on peut
dans un certain nombre de cas surseoir à
statuer sur tel point passer un autre
article les évoqué quand il faut voilà
utiliser tous les moyens
il faut qu'on examine absolument tous
les amendements de ce texte car je
remercie monsieur le président nous
passons donc à l'amendement une série de
16 amendements identiques 1,25 par dont
on n'a pas mis aux voix le précédent je
m'en excuse
on n'avait pas vivre l'autre amendement
voix madame autant donc sur les dix sept
amendements identiques qui ont été
débattus qu'ancien avis défavorable de
la commission et vient de manquer pour
qui est contre il est donc rejeté
monsieur l'arrivée un peu règlement
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais faire un rappel au règlement
sur le fondement de l'article 95
il serait utile que le ministre des
relations avec le parlement va bien
répondre à l'interrogation que eric
woerth comme jean luc mélenchon du reste
ont formulé on est saisi d'un article
premier dont le conseil d'état nous
expliquer qu'il n'avait pas de valeur
normative en vertu d'une jurisprudence
constante du conseil communal depuis
2003 toutes les discussions qui portent
sur l'article 1er sont en réalité des
discussions qui portent quasiment
comment dire sur des principes et
thérèse ont fait pas de droit en ce
moment n'est pas en train de faire la
loi
la loi leur donne elle permet ou à
l'interdît voilà là c'est un article
déclaratif c'est vous monsieur le
ministre et le gouvernement qui nous
saisit d'un article déclaratif et c'est
pour ça que depuis cinq jours ces débats
sont à ce point filandreux parce que
tout le monde parle un petit peu de
têtes chose de ta de principe
vous avez vous le gouvernement dans les
mains ce pouvoir très important qui nous
permettrait d'aller sur le fond vous
pouvez utiliser les dispositions de
l'article 95 du règlement vous pouvez
choisir de créer un vrai débat sur les
articles normatif
pourquoi vous le faites pas est ce que
vous ne faites pas vous monsieur le
ministre à la fiac le parlement au nom
du premier ministre nom d'emmanuel
macron pour le coup un jeu qui
consisterait de manière extrêmement
cynique a laissé pourrir les débats pour
pouvoir nous dire dans quelques jours ah
ben on peut pas débattre et donc 49 3
voilà la vérité vous êtes pardonnez-moi
démasqué alors répondez nous pourquoi
vous n'appelez pas des articles normatif
en vertu de l'article 95 du règlement je
vous remercie à monsieur le ministre a
souhaité intervenir
monsieur je mène merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je ne résiste pas au plaisir de répondre
à monsieur l'arrivée il temps là depuis
cinq jours je vois à peu près comment se
déroulent les débats avec mon collègue
pas de pietra zewski
d'abord je voudrais rappeler ne nous
cachons pas derrière les mots et je le
dis aussi avec tout le respect que je
dois au président mélenchon vous avez
assumé publiquement
la volonté de faire obstruction au texte
non mais vous l'avez dit vous vous
l'avez dit partout ça s'est répandu sur
l'ensemble des choses je j'ai fait la
distinction
j'ai fait la distinction je regarde
assez les débats pour savoir et j'ai
suffisamment insisté pour faire la
distinction
monsieur mélenchon chacun doit assumer
ses actes et chacun doit assumer ses
propos vous avez fait le choix non
seulement sur l'article 1 et ça me
permet en partie de répondre à monsieur
l'arrivée mais ne me dites pas que vous
n'avez pas regardé la suite des
amendements qui sont déposés sur le
texte ou sur les neuf 185 alinéa de ce
texte il est proposé simplement de les
supprimer alors si ce ne sont pas des
manoeuvres d'obstruction mais libre
libre au groupe qu'ils ont fait aux deux
groupes qui l'ont fait de prendre la
décision de la décision d'aller au fond
des débats au groupe qui l'ont fait
d'aller au fond des débats et d'éviter
par des manoeuvres d'obstruction
évidente comme alinéa par alinéa vous
choisissez de supprimer par amendement
par amendement vous supprimez de
supprimer tous les alinéas sans aucun
autre motif que celui de dire je fait de
l'obstruction assumer les choses et nous
nous assumons les nôtres mais nous nous
voulons aller au bout du débat monsieur
virer l'un de vos collègues hier 10 est
une chose assez juste et je je je ne
résiste pas au plaisir de te dire à
monsieur mélenchon que j'ai été
intéressé par le fait qu' il avait parlé
il a été par les de la sphère du temps
législatif programmé mais il a été
proposé et je reconnais volontiers que
le groupe les républicains l'avaient
acceptée cueillez et d'autre il ya deux
groupes qui sont posées aux tempes
législatif programmé pas à 50 heures à
120 heures
c'est vous qui l'avez refusé et je
voyais monsieur mélenchon hier applaudir
sur la ville à la question du temps
législatif programmé mais alors acceptez
le il fallait l'accepter
l'arrêt de ces cinquante heures vous
avez refusé 120 et donc le gouvernement
pour répondre à monsieur l'arrivée ils
étaient prêts au débat et il est
toujours prêt au débat maintenant il
faut se conformer les actes les paroles
et les gestes et donc c'est ça que je
crois qu'on est en droit d'attendre
merci
j'ai un peu un rappel au règlement
monsieur jumelles de l'article 95
d'abord je note que notre collègue
l'arrivée conseiller d'état et donc qui
pose des questions avec expertise n'a
pas eu de réponse à sa question
deuxièmement le ministre nous raconte
l'histoire comme il veut mais il oublie
de préciser que si le gouvernement avait
respecté les règles élémentaires de
dépôt de textes de six semaines de délai
il aurait pu décider d'un temps
législatif programmé son accord de qui
que ce soit et donc la date du 17
février
l'impérieuse nécessité pour emmanuel
macron de solder cette nouvelle affaire
avant les municipales qui est
responsable de ça qui est responsable
d'avoir décidé de forcer la main aux
français sur ce mauvais projet vous et
donc il ya principe en droit et il ya
même un principe en politique nul ne
peut se prévaloir de ses propres
turpitudes et dans le domaine de ce
projet de loi vous avez de nombreuses
turpitudes
par ailleurs vous avez la main sur la
conduite des débats vous pouvez à tout
moment mettre des articles en réserve
décidé d'un temps plus large pour
examiner un article si vous ne le faites
pas c'est que la décision a été prise
sans vous là haut tout seul entendant
les expertises de ceux qui sont dans une
extrême solitude et qui marche seul
contre le pape qui marche seul contre le
parlement qui marche seul contre les
organisations syndicales
et donc voilà le le truc est écrit
depuis plusieurs jours enfin on se fait
aucune illusion qu'on ait ou non déposer
des amendements vous avez décidé de
passer au forceps et donc vous allez le
payer et vous allez le payer cher
et vous allez le payer aux municipales
non monsieur jumelles c'est bon monsieur
alors attendez j'ai monsieur mélenchon
que j'ai vu dans sa demande de rappel au
règlement puis madame du monde
attendez un problème de micro est-ce que
imprégné du micro ali est visé
ce n'est pas de la censure organisé un
jeu je vous préviens par contre essayer
à nouveau s'il vous plaît sinon je vais
vous demander de changer de micro 1
voilà comme ça nous entendrons tous vos
propos monsieur mélenchon
ça y est ça marche bon je ne peux faire
moi et deux en invoquant sur la base
arctique 86,1 au ministre des relations
avec le parlement bon on viens de vous
le dire si vous vouliez le temps de
programmer il fallait vous y prendre à
temps imaginez vous que je suis le
président d'un groupe d'opposition et
que l'on me demande au débotté en soir
si je suis d'accord pour revenir le
lendemain pour changer toute la règle du
jeu et on me dit eh bien si on le décide
dès qu'on est tous d'accord alors on
change tout ce qu'on veut la réponse a
été après consultation mon groupe non
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
l'expression politique d'un mouvement je
comprends que n'accepte pas mais nous
sommes l'expression politique de sa de
gens qui se sont mis en grève à qui on a
dit 'nous on part en vacances on vous
reverra au retour qu'on continue qu'on
continuer leur grève contre tenu bon et
par conséquent nous nous sentons dans le
rôle de devoir comme eux tenir bon pied
à pied voilà alors après vous vous
étonnez du fait qu'on fasse des
amendements de suppression de monsieur
le ministre vous touchez du doigt une
réalité profonde c'est que nous sommes
opposés à tout le texte et par
conséquent nous n'allons pas l'améliorer
il n'est pas améliorable parce que il
est incohérent il est plein de trous par
ordonnance il est il ne tient pas debout
il ya des endroits où il ya des critères
qui n'existe pas etc etc
donc nous sommes contre et donc nous
alinéa par alinéa nous exprimons que
nous sommes contre en demandant la
suppression et à chaque fois nous le
faisons au nom d'un argument de fond sur
l'organisation générale depuis que vous
nous menacez du 49-3 dans un usage
anticonstitutionnelle nous nous sentons
encore plus voilà c'est tout merci alors
donc nous faisons la grève du zèle parce
que nous sommes menacés d'interruption
de débat par le 49 3 et vous passez
votre temps ça c'est vous même qui
provoqué des incidents à rallonge toute
la journée
chers collègues les rappels au règlement
sont quand même sur le s'il vous plaît
les rappels règlements sont quand même
sur la réalité de nos débats donc je
vais en prendre encore quelques-uns dès
lors qu'il ne rentre pas dans une boucle
qui ne s'arrêterait pas madame du monde
toujours sur la base du 95 de l'article
95 que monsieur l'arrivée a eu
effectivement bien raison de citer mais
il faudrait peut-être le lire parce que
tout le monde n'est pas spécialiste non
plus du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale et nous nous sommes là
législateur pour faire la loi mais aussi
pour défendre cette institution
parlementaire à laquelle on tient et
donc le 95 l'article 95 alinéa 4
je le cite la réserve où la priorité
d'un article d'un amendement dont
l'objet est de modifier l'ordre de la
discussion peut toujours être demandé et
puis il faut lire l'article l'alinéa
suivant
madame la présidente justement je
m'adresse également à vous elles sont de
droit c'est-à-dire la réserve où la
priorité d'un article d'un événement
elles sont de droit à la demande du
gouvernement ou de la commission saisie
au fond
donc vous voyez bien que vous avez tous
les moyens d'organiser cette discussion
dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez si vous
considérez qu'il y a trop d'amendements
même si nos groupes socialistes nous
n'en avons pas déposer plus que le
groupe la république en marche quand
grand bien vous fasse
inverser la discussion et rentrons dans
la technique
encore une fois ne nous reprochez pas
d'avoir déposé des amendements puisque
vous avez la main le gouvernement ou la
commission au fond d'organiser les
débats comme ils vous sied donc
sincèrement ne renversez pas la charge
de la preuve et prenez vos
responsabilités
président sur la base de l'article sans
nous nous avions créé cette possibilité
de temps programmé ça correspond
parfaitement à ce type de grand débat
très large on doit dire les choses bon
je comprends que le gouvernement n'ait
pas réussi à tenir les six semaines très
très bien mais dans d'autres cas nous
avions repousser la date d'examen du
texte lui même si le texte est entré un
peu tardivement à l'assemblée nationale
il suffisait de repousser la date
d'examen vous auriez pu faire et à ce
moment là on aurait eu un débat à mon
avis plus serein plus calme je ne sais
pas pourquoi vous vous êtes précipité
comme cela pour engager dans ces
conditions là sur un texte incomplet un
texte de cette nature
merci monsieur le président toujours sur
la base de l'article sans rappel au
règlement le sujet n'est en rien
juridique
ça n'est pas une question de procédure
parlementaire du droit ou du non droit
que certains seraient est fondé à
déposer des amendements nous ne
contestons en rien votre droit
d'amendement d'aucune manière le sujet
non non il dit
il est irréductible il est même
constitutionnel le sujet il est
politique et notre responsabilité est de
dissiper l'hypocrisie qui anime votre
stratégie de débat parlementaire
vous l'avez très bien dit président
mélenchon votre sujet n'est pas
d'enrichir le texte ni même de le
contester ni même de l'amendé il est de
faire en sorte qu'ils ne voient jamais
le jour
c'est ça votre objectif politique
non mais si parce que votre but n'est
pas du tout de mener ce débat à son
terme le but est que le débat n'ait pas
lieu pour que la loi ne soit jamais voté
merci on pourrait avoir dix mille
amendements de plus il en a mille
amendements - votre objet
tiff est de faire en sorte que jamais ce
débat ne prenne fin ne vous mêlez ci est
inverse
cette loi sera votée vous remercie
monsieur le président vigier oui merci
nous fait président pense qu'avec notre
groupe depuis la première minute de ce
débat et notamment lors de la discussion
générale sans expliquer que les choix du
gouvernement de poser une date limite
était un mauvais choix et j'avais
expliqué que le 49-3 sera au bout du
chemin c'était la fin de mon
intervention
donc nous ne l'acceptons pas que l'on
soit comme cela dans une partie de ping
pong infernal sachant qu'il y a un texte
considère al 350 milliards d'euros à la
clé et le système de réforme de retraite
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
donc moi je dis au gouvernement et jeudi
également nos collègues de l'opposition
qu'il faut que l'on trouve une sortie
dans cette affaire là tout le monde sera
perdant
c'est la puissance publique au final qui
sera au rendez vous mes chers collègues
je vous le dis calculez soit les tests
qui arriveront un jour ou l'autre
et bien si les obstructions permanente
se crée bien jamais nous ne pourrons
rien faire et donc il appartient
lorsqu'on a la main et je le redis au
gouvernement que c'était aussi à vous a
trouvé un système dans lequel on ne soit
pas enfermé en annonçant la date du 3
mars ont créé les conditions de
l'impuissance
je l'avais dit en conférence des
présidents généreux dit au ministre en
charge
on doit sortir de cette impasse et
pouvait pas nous dit à 4 du moment on
était obstacle au quotidien nous sommes
exprimés une seule fois ce matin par la
voix de jeanine dubié donc franchement
il ya quelques années que c'est dans
cette maison mais voir à quel point nous
en sommes ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
et qui voit ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
imaginons une seconde une seconde ce que
nous représentons
on ne peut continuer ainsi ce le
ministre il faut que l'on trouve une
solution
on ne peut pas avoir cette date butoir
le 49-3 serait naturellement la négation
je dis bien la négation sur un tel sujet
on va tous parlé du conseil national de
la résistance
sur un des fondements de la république
se serait dénoncé vous le dire aux
collègues de la majorité ne vous mettez
pas dans ses draps confortable
d'imaginer que l'obstruction fera que
l'obstruction les générés par la méthode
qui a été choisi par le gouvernent
j'aurais rêvé de dire à ce monsieur le
président mignola que monsieur le
président mélenchon oui pour que chaque
président de groupe puisse s'exprimer
dans le cadre de ces rappels au
règlement au titre des articles sans et
95 parce que j'imagine que la présidente
de la commission qui a été interpellé
j'ignore si le gouvernement voudrait
reprendre la parole sur ce sujet mais ce
qui nous est proposé
c'est donc de pouvoir à partir de cet
article le premier sauté sur d'autres
articles
il se trouve que depuis le début de la
commission spéciale et depuis le début
de cette semaine je le signale à mon à
mon collègue l'arrivée à chaque fois
qu'on a évoqué les femmes
hop on a sauté sur les agriculteurs à
chaque fois qu'on évoquait les
agriculteurs up or sautait sur la
pénibilité ce qui pouvait parfois aller
ensemble mais pas tout à fait et puis
sur la pénibilité après on est revenu à
la valeur du point de la valeur du point
on est passés ou pib enfin on vit dans
une faille spatio-temporelle depuis
trois semaines donc rien on peut quand
même pas désormais demander au
gouvernement ou à la présidente de la
commission de décider de faire ce que en
réalité toutes les oppositions toutes
font depuis le début de ce texte pour le
ralentir monsieur mélenchon je vous
propose un arrangement
mais oui je vois que vous vous exalté
pour rien alors si j'ai bien compris à
d'abord un mot quand même président
legendre mais il ya aucune hypocrisie
vous ne rêvez derrien vous n'êtes pas le
pawlinski de cet hémicycle
nous assumons le fait que nous sommes
contre ce texte
nous sommes contre nous sommes contre
cette réforme et on essaye de vous
l'expliquer et nous faisons ce que nous
pouvons pour faire en sorte qu'ils ne
soient pas adoptés en effet je vois pas
ce qu'il ya là dedans de scandaleux de
choquant bon ça s'appelle une opposition
président legendre faut intégrer la
faire un dans une république il ya une
majorité et une opposition et en plus
nous y en a plusieurs de l'opposition
alors vous êtes vous avez de la chance
finalement magazine sur fond
d'opposition puisque l'article 95 que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et
qu'apparemment mes collègues reprennent
à leur tour en disant que en effet il
permet cela si vous pensez qu'on est
trop dans les généralités à cet instant
choisissez un article qui vous parle est
techniquement fondée sur lequel nous
interviendrons et donc je vous fais la
proposition parce que l'article 95
alinéa 5 dit que soit c'est le
gouvernement qui change
auquel cas ces deux droits n'y a pas à
discuter ou la commission saisie au fond
quelqu'un il n'y a pas à discuter ou
bien dans les autres cas le président
décide
voilà où sinon on peut même voté donc
président vous êtes vous pouvez faire
une petite suspension de séance pour
réfléchir et demandé au gouvernement ou
à monsieur legendre à qui je je tiens à
être agréable à cet instant 1 quel est
l'article qui lui conviendrait quel est
l'article qui vous conviendrait cher
président legendre
s'il ya un article qui vous arrange
parce qu'il est plus technique de fonds
de fonds que de technique et ben nous
sommes prêts
l'article que vous voulez à l'endroit
que vous voulez nous sommes prêts à en
discuter à 95 alinéa 5 président tout
est dans vos cheveux remercie faire une
interruption de séance ont fait une
longue pause déjeuner dans quelques
instants
mais monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de commission vont prendre la
parole j'ai laissé s'exprimer
ces rappels règlement qui me semble
important pour le la tenue de nos débats
vous remarquerez que je n'ai pas fait
appel aux 58.3 ou 58.4 pour les sévices
cette discussion qui me semblent
importantes
dès lors qu'elles ne se prolongera pas
de façon obstructive
monsieur le ministre merci mais monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
j'entends le président mélenchon et ça
me rappelle une citation l'heure est aux
diplomates et aux tables rondes
c'est toujours intéressant qu'on puisse
trouver des gens qui essayent de travail
à 20 jours et répondre sur le fond
madame du monde d'abord vous dire il n'y
a pas de question de reproches sur les
amendements j'ai été un de ce camp avait
révoqué cette question du droit
individuel les amendements à dire que
c'était un droit constitutionnel qu'il
fallait continuer donc je suis assez
cohérent de penser et j'essaie d'être
cohérent tout court donc géoïde a aucun
sujet de cette nature là mais après je
disais tout à l'heure d'ailleurs ça ne
nous était pas principalement adressées
au groupe social et je veux dire qu'il
fallait aussi dans la même cohérence
assumer la volonté non pas d'aller au
bout du texte et d'empêcher qu'ils
soient votées mais d'empêcher tout
simplement qu'il soit débattu et au fond
c'est ça ce qui est à l'oeuvre
on ne peut pas débattre on est au
cinquième alinéa de l'article 1er
il ya neuf 185 alinéa la vérité c'est
qu'à ce rythme là il va falloir
plusieurs années sauf qu'à ce que
monsieur mélenchon nous propose
d'allonger la la durée du mandat
parlementaire de deux ou trois années
pour que nous puissions aller au bout de
ce texte et je vois qu'au fond ils ne
pourraient partager ce sentiment
dans vous voudriez de plus + nombreux
sans doute mais en tout cas je vois
voudriez prolonger mais je pense qu'on
va être contraint avec la durée des
débats tels qu'ils sont sous nos yeux
pour dire les choses très simplement
la deuxième chose c'est que je disais
monsieur je voudrais pas là monsieur
jumelles qui disait en fait vous nous
dites que vous préférez la contrainte au
contrat sur le temps législatif
programmé ou préféreriez vous préfériez
les six lettres qui a posé avoue 50
heures que le contrat qui vous ont
proposé 120 jeux jeux tour je trouve ça
assez fascinant comme ministre des
relations avec le parlement
d'entendre des parlementaires nous dire
mais contraignez nous ben si c'est la
vérité de ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est la vérité ce que vous avez dit
c'est c'est factuellement ce que vous
avez dit s'il y avait vous aviez eu les
objets de la contrainte on pouvait rien
dire et on vous proposait un contrat
monsieur jumelles et vous ne voulez pas
un contrat et c'était le double du temps
législatif programmé
c'est à dire le double de la réforme de
2008 tête qu'elle avait été quelques
avait été prévu jeudi enfin je dis enfin
y compris à tous ceux qui se sont
exprimés comme ça personne ne se sentira
visé
personnellement et ça évitera 1 58 tirs
et 4
je prends toutes les précautions
oratoires avant enfin quand même venir
nous reprocher ce matin est reproché à
cette majorité à ce gouvernement la
volonté de l'obstruction la volonté de
refuser les débats
la volonté d' essayer d'éclairer les bas
les débats j'ai souvenir d'une publicité
je le dis à ceux qui sont exprimés en ce
sens qu'ils disaient tu pousses le
bouchon un peu loin maurice et je pense
qu'on en est là où
[Musique]
bien je vais laisser la parole à la
présidente de commission et après et
après nous suspendrons pour nos travaux
pour la pause déjeuner madame la
présidente
mais ces présidents juste parce que le
ministre a précisé jean j'en discuterai
avec lui après mais puisque j'ai été
interpelé évidemment on peut toujours
choisir cette méthode choisir un article
ou pas sauf que si on revient aux
principes mêmes de base de ce qu'on
s'est dit et de ce que le président
mélenchon a rappelé tout à l'heure
puisque vous êtes opposé par nature et
sur le fond et sur le principe nous
avons et sur le principe nous avons
autant d'articles de suppression et
d'alinéa donc à part sur encore
l'incohérence supplémentaires qu on y
ajouterait à butiner dans le texte
ainsi voilà donc à peser mais je pense
que ça ne changera pas grand chose à la
volonté inébranlable qui est la vôtre
que de vouloir arrêter les débats
donc voilà c'est tout moi je ne suis pas
contre 1 là vous remercie nous aurons
donc qu à l'occasion de ses différentes
expressions sur des rappels règlement
parler du fond de nos travaux
parlementaires je l'en remercie
la prochaine séance cet après midi à 15h
sur la suite du projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite je
souhaite à toutes et à tous un bon
appétit la séance et